bonjour à tout bon jour à tous nous
sommes très heureux de vous retrouver à
sur les réseaux sociaux sur le site
internet de la roue tourangelle mais
également sur le site de france
télévision france 3 centre val de loire
pour la 19ème édition de la roue
tourangelle une roue tourangelle qui a
bel et bien tourné avec un retour aux
hostilités en cette saison 2021
après un an d'absence en raison
évidemment des conditions que vous
connaissez malgré ce contexte sanitaire
est bien un coup de chapeau à
l'organisation de bernard mâchefers et
toute son équipe qui a réussi à aller au
bout des choses pour mettre sur pied
cette 19ème édition de la roue
tourangelle nous serons ensemble
et bien tout au long de cet après midi
pour vivre ensemble cette troisième
épreuve de la coupe de france de
cyclisme et à mes côtés bien pour nous
accompagner cet après midi qui d'autre
qu'un un coureur cycliste tourangeau ex
coureur professionnel c'est jérémy roy
bonjour jérémy bonjour bonjour à tous
très heureux de vous retrouver jérémy
sous sur un parcours évidemment que vous
connaissez bien puisque ça a été
longtemps très longtemps vos routes
d'entraînement oui tout à fait c'est
vrai que je suis né à tours j'ai grandi
a toujours je suis resté à tour durant
ma carrière professionnelle donc c'est
des routes que je connais que j'ai déjà
parcouru dans ma jeunesse lors de lors
des courses amateurs et voilà j'ai
malheureusement pu faire qu'une fois la
roue tourangelle en tant que
professionnel je suis ravi d'être à vos
côtés aujourd'hui pour la commenter
et voir un petit peu ce que ça va donner
sur ce sur cette course un petit peu
atypique avec un final casse pape
exposés au vent mon le vent et n'en
reste aujourd'hui on verra ça
son influence on découvre justement le
parcours avant de retrouver les
premières images en direct
le parcours d'une édition de la roue
tourangelle a qui changent chaque année
de ville départ à les coureurs se sont
élancés tout à l'heure aux alentours de
12 heures
depuis la localité de sainte maure de
touraine et on voyait se profile loin
d'être plat est une course qui a des
allures de classique 1 cette édition de
la roue tourangelle
oui c'est sûr c'est mal placé fait pas
non plus une région très montagneuse
comme comme chacun le sait mais c'est
tout le temps des petites bosses des
petits enchaînements et surtout des
petites routes comme on peut le voir à
l'écran actuellement avec des portions
qui sont parfois exposés au vent et puis
ce final qui sera assez spectaculaire 40
km
les derniers quarante kilomètres il y
aura les coteaux de la loire et du cher
à gravir à sept reprises et ce dernier
tour de circuit final pour arriver
boulevard jean royer un petit tour de
circuit de 3 km environ
donc c'est ouvert c'est une course assez
ouverte on l'a vu sur les palmarès du
passé ça peut c'est possible si une
arrivée massive mais c'est aussi
possible qu'ils aient des
échappée au long cours comme il ya deux
ans où des petites échappées qui partent
dans ce fameux final dans les derniers
quarante kilomètres
effectivement jérémy la dernière édition
s'était déroulée il ya deux ans et ce
jour-là l'échappée matinale était allé
au bout avait réussi à fausser compagnie
au peloton des sprinteurs jusqu'au bout
donc on aura évidemment un autre élément
de réponse tout à l'heure alors beaucoup
de montées alors certes l'altitude n'est
pas très hautain ici à dans ce
département d'indre et loire dans la
belle province de touraine
mais la multiplication des ascensions
elle sera peut-être l'élément évidemment
à prendre en compte avec pas moins de
vingt-huit côte répertoriée tout au long
1 du circuit
alors cette rentrer dans le classement
du meilleur grimpeur mais il y en a
beaucoup qui elles ne sont pas
répertoriés justement dans ce classement
là mais qui est participeront a créé la
sélection oui on va pas mettre un
classement grimpeur à chaque chaque
petite côte
ferrell mais ça fait partie de l'usure
engendrés par le parcours et puis aussi
une distance 1 204 km au programme
aujourd'hui
un départ fictif qui est pas
comptabilisés dans ces danses et 204 km
donc c'est long et puis ce vent qui est
nord est qui et qui rend la course un
peu plus difficile puisque la course
partant de sainte-maure arrivant à tour
la majeure partie du parcours avait est
proposé avec avant plutôt défavorable
donc pas propice malheureusement à cette
échappée qui doit affronter ce vent mais
on peut voir que cette échappée
progresse avec trois minutes 10 d'avancé
actuellement qui reprend un petit peu de
marge puisque le peloton contrôlé
environ à 2 minutes 30 de pi depuis le
départ alors parlons-en justement de
cette situation de course vous indiquiez
les carences et les quarts maximale
enregistrée depuis le départ ce midi
trois minutes et 10 secondes d'avancé
pour les cinq hommes de tête dont
l'identité vous êtes actuellement
présenté à l'écran avec notamment deux
coureurs français dans ce quinté de tête
il y à dylan kowalski le coureur de
l'équipe axelis roubaix lille métropole
il est accompagné dylan kowalski par
valentin ferron qui est ici en quatrième
position avec son maillot
bleu-blanc-rouge de la formation total
direct energie on leur compagnie il y a
également un orthézien martin uriane
stats qui est en dernière
mission un maillot jaune et rouge de la
formation u know it's le delko à que
l'on découvre avec le dossard 72 c'est
l'italien alessandro fedeli qui est
peut-être parmi ces cinq là celui qui
présente le plus de références 1 d'un
point de vue du palmarès on y reviendra
également dans quelques minutes et puis
le cinquième homme et bien le voici en
rouge et noir en cinquième position
maintenant à la faveur de cette prise de
relais c'est le suisse
théry schir un coureur de 28 ans qui
représente donc la confédération
helvétique et qui complètent cette
échappée une échappée qui donc compte
plus de trois minutes d'avancé mais le
peloton n'a jamais laissé plus d' avance
à ce groupe peut-être se remémorant
jérémy ce qui s'est passé il ya deux ans
avec une échappée qui est allé au bout
un qui avait conduit à la victoire de
lionel taminiaux ce jour-là à l'échappée
matinale à des prix jusqu'à 7 minutes
d'avancé oui c'est sûr peloton n'a pas
voulu refaire la même erreur
et puis bah y'a quand même des belles
têtes d'affiché aujourd'hui pour pour
jouer à sprinter éventuellement donc on
peut le voir c'est là la groupama fdj
qui roule actuellement qui affronteront
saint arnaud démare donc qui peut qui
peut être prétendre à la victoire bien
entendu cette équipe a été appuyé par
les intermarchés one thing auber
matériaux qui en sont salle andré apas
colonnes donc ce sont deux équipes qui
essayent de cadenasser un petit peu même
si actuellement en tête c'est du coup là
groupama fdj et le coureur qui roule et
c'est bien ça me semble-t-il un coureur
de l'équipe
intermarché au one thing aubert
matériaux qui est également devant alors
cela tombe bien puisque la prise
d'antenne est effective depuis quelques
minutes seulement on est à mi course
mesdames messieurs vous n'avez rien
manquer ou presque de cette première
partie de course du côté de la touraine
avec cette échappée qui s'est formée à
ses taux au 15e kilomètre échappé à cinq
et un peloton qui roule de manière assez
régulière derrière on va donc vivre
ensemble la deuxième partie la plus
importante de cette 19ème édition de la
roue tourangelle
avec un plateau vous commenciez en
parlais tout à l'heure un plateau à xxl
peut-être même le plus beau plateau que
la course n'ait jamais connue en 20 ans
d'existence
oui c'est sûr on n'a parlé que de
deux équipes mais faut pas oublier que
ag2r citroën est venu en force également
avec pas mal de coureurs qui peuvent
prétendre à la victoire
dorian godon quatrième à cholet marc
sarreau 5e à cholet qui était victorieux
ici sur la route tourangelle il y a
trois ans maintenant de mémoire et qui a
fait 3e il ya deux ans donc juste
derrière les deux les deux échappés
clément venturini qui est rapide
également aux primes c'est qu'il est
capable de passer ces bosses dans le
final où hans peter ce qui est capable
de dynamiser aussi ce final donc équipe
à suivre l'équipe ag2r
on peut retrouver aussi l'équipe arkia
qui bien sûr a en son sein acerbois
nikki qui a envie de briller de lever
les bras avec son son lanceur
thomas boudât way 22 équipages ont pris
le départ à ce matin ils ont toutes été
présenté en amont du départ du côté de
sainte maure
du côté de la ville départ de cette
édition à 2021 204 km c'est le parcours
le plus long dans l'histoire de la
course avec donc 22 équipes elle devait
être 23 mai une formation a dû déclarer
forfait à quelques heures du départ avec
un malheureusement plusieurs cadres
qu'ovide nos causses en inde une seule
et même formation toujours et il est
bien que cette épreuve est aussi le
support de la troisième manche de la
coupe de france déjà deux épreuves ont
eu lieu du côté de marseille le
traditionnel grand prix la marseillaise
avec a ouvert la saison en europe 1
victoire ce jour-là de aurélien pas
répondre et puis du côté de cholet
également le la classique cholet pays de
loire qui s'est déroulé à dimanche
dernier avec la victoire au sprint de
elia viviani la coupe de france fdj donc
deux cyclisme un peloton qui navigue
dans la deuxième partie de course qui
signifie jérémy si l'on s'en fie au
parcours que les coureurs vont rejoindre
une deuxième fois à dans quelques
minutes la ville départ à savoir sainte
maure de touraine
oui c'est exactement ça les courants ont
fait une boucle dans le sud du
département en allant chercher ma gni
marmande fait la vineuse ou la localité
de richelieu ils reviennent actuellement
sur sainte maure donc lieu du départ de
la course avant de redire sur heroes
bifurquer vers saintes et pain et pour
aller chercher le final sur un zèle
rideaux et les rives du cher se pointent
à sept morts sera un petit peu
technique étendue puisque les coureurs
auront un petit peu vent de côté à la
sortie de sainte maure donc ce qu'on
verra des hostilités des équipes tenter
de durcir la course
ça va être un point important à suivre
très prochainement
on aura la chance donc d'avoir
effectivement les commentaires experts
de jérémy roy tout au long de cet après
midi on est déjà très heureux de vous
convier très nombreux sur le live a live
streaming qui est organisé par par les
profs justement pour vous permettre de
suivre au mieux à les coureurs dans
cette édition de la roue tourangelle
échappé à cinq et un qui navigue depuis
déjà et bien 90 km aux avant postes avec
dylan kowalski martin ryan stade théry
schir valentin ferron et alessandro fait
dali et un peloton donc effectivement à
plus de trois minutes
jérémy pour revenir donc à cette édition
de la roue tourangelle vous connaissent
évidemment fort bien les routes mais
vous n'avez pas finalement couru si
souvent cette épreuve dans votre
carrière
mais non parce que cette épreuve été
longtemps en classe 2 donc je ne pouvais
pas pas concourir avec mon équipe
et puis après au niveau du calendrier se
situer souvent le jour de
liège-bastogne-liège
du coup j'ai été souvent sur ces courses
ardennaises donc malheureusement j'ai pu
faire qu'une seule fois la roue
tourangelle
c'est un immense plaisir de courir à
domicile mais c'est vrai que c'est un
grand plaisir aujourd'hui de de l'autre
côté de la barrière de pouvoir un petit
peu au 20e vrai pour la roue tourangelle
et la vive d'une autre façon on se
remémore justement ce jour là c'est en
2013 que jérémy roy était non peloton de
cette course victoire justement d'un
coureur de l'équipe fdj à l'époque
c'était michaël delage peut être tout à
fait j'étais un petit peu protégés ce
jour là j'ai tenté ma chance à plusieurs
reprises et puis voyant que j'arrivais
pas fait la différence jeu on a changé
de stratégie et j'ai dit à michael qu'on
roulait pour lui soit dix derniers
kilomètres
on a réussi à l'emmener
à la victoire donc c'est vrai que ça
fait un beau souvenir c'est que michael
aussi généralement un équipier qui n'a
pas l'occasion de lever les bras et
jouer sa carte souvent donc c'était une
belle victoire collective
alors c'est votre ancienne équipe que
dix chez votre équipe actuelle puisque
vous avez encore des activités au sein
de l'équipe groupama fdj qui a pris
peloton en main l'équipe groupama fdj
elle elle est venue avec évidemment
beaucoup d'ambitions avec son champion
de france arnaud démare arnaud qui a
besoin de se rassurer un et tourne
autour depuis le début de la saison on
rappelle qu'il était le meilleur
performeur de la saison 2020 en nombre
de victoires les 14e succès il attend sa
première victoire et il est venu pour ça
aujourd'hui du côté de tours will est
venu pour ça c'est sûr il a quand même
fait 2e d'une étape de paris nice en
début de saison mais il a changé son
programme aussi habituellement il fait
le tour des flandres
avant d'avant paris roubaix mais cette
année il avait déjà décidé de ne pas le
couvrir
donc c'est bien aussi de varier un petit
peu
d'élargir le spectre c'est bien qu'il
vienne aussi sur ces coupes de france
pour pour un petit peu la monnaie de la
pièce à tous les organisateurs tous tous
ces bénévoles qui mettent beaucoup de
choses en place pour organiser des
courses ça reste malgré tout une belle
gueule pas une belle victoire en cas de
victoire bien sûr mais ça c'est des
courses qui marque ce et des coupes de
france donc c'est pas négligeable
ouais une ligne de plus à son palmarès
peut être tout à l'heure mais il y aura
évidemment beaucoup de concurrence
arnaud démare qui est arrivé avec son
train de fidèles poisson pilote puisque
dans l'équipe groupama fdj sont alignés
des coureurs d'expérience comme
l'italien iacopo guarniéri à qui sera
peut-être l'élément qui lui permettra
d'aller chercher la victoire tout à
l'heure dans cette belle dernière ligne
droite 1 400 mètres de ligne droite pour
nous permettre évidemment d'en savoir
plus et puis ramon sinkeldam ignatas
konovalovas ce bref ca le train habituel
d'arnaud démare qui figurent sur cette
19ème édition de la roue tourangelle
pour le moment ce sont les équipiers
d'autres équipiers d'arnaud démare qui
assure un le travail avec notamment le
jeune paul penhoët mais également le
britannique lewis heskey qui sont là
pour prendre de l'expérience et cela
passe par le travail de l'ombre quand on
quand on débute
et puis c'est important de souligner que
ces coureurs en fait sont dans l'équipe
continentale
oppama fdj sont pas des cordes qui pour
le tour c'est une particularité assez
récente du cio autorise comme ça de les
coureurs des équipes réserves de venir
faire des courses avec l'équipe première
et ça marche aussi dans l'autre sens à
un coureur de l'équipe pour le tour peut
éventuellement aller courir sur une
course de catégorie moindre avec
l'équipe continentale donc c'est bien
pour les retours de blessures ou des
remises en condition et pour ces jeunes
au contraire c'est bien pour prendre de
l'expérience et courir déjà avec
l'équipe pour le tour donc c'est une
bonne chose pour ses équipes de
développement de pouvoir participer à
ces courses avec les équipes pour le
tour on surveillera effectivement leurs
prestations tout au long de cet après
midi dans de bonnes conditions puisque
le soleil brille aujourd'hui un petit
peu devant vous l'avez fait remarquer
tout à l'heure mais un vent qui ne
semble pas gêner le comportement des
coureurs puisqu'ils souffle bien de la
bonne manière comment comment on peut
expliquer sa jérémy fain dépend de la
bonne manière pour qui ça tourne
beaucoup ça tourne à gauche ça tourne à
droite
non mais hier le vent était beaucoup
plus inquiétant pour les courses et un
avant très très soutenu 30 à 40 km h
avec des rafales à 60
aujourd'hui c'est que 15 km heure des
rafales à 35 40 ven majoritairement
défavorables donc c'est pour les
sprinteurs j'ai envie de dire c'est
mieux fondées favorable on dit que
généralement ccca c'est contraire aux
échappées voilà la course
un petit peu moins débridée même s'il a
forcément les boss vont se faire vent
dans le dos vent favorable donc quand
même falloir accrocher le bon wagon
les coureurs sont à 90 km exactement 1
de cette arrivée aujourd'hui 19e arrivé
dans l'histoire de l'épreuve chère à
bernard mâche faire la roue tourangelle
qui présente un palmarès qui s'étoffe
évidemment année après année le tenant
du titre n'est pas présent lionel
taminiaux qui s'était imposée il ya deux
ans au terme d'une belle échappée
matinale conduite en compagnie de robin
carpenter le coureur américain à ces
deux là avaient réussi à résister au
retour du peloton et est à mignot
s'était imposé 1 taminiaux qui avait
enlevé ce jour là la plus belle victoire
de sa jeune carrière à qui lui a permis
de rejoindre une une formation encore
plus huppés puisqu'il fait partie
maintenant de l'équipe de mathieu
vanderpool la formation alpine phoenix
qui n'est pas présente sur les routes à
deux tours les routes tourangelle donc
tout au long de cet après midi les
échappées que l'on retrouve avec un
valentin ferron ici en discussion avec
son directeur sportif à valentin
ferroukhi découvre la course c'est sa
première participation le jeune coureur
poitevin qui ne résident pas très loin
d'ici
pas très loin de l'indre-et-loire 23 ans
lui qui a pour principal fait d'armes
d'avoir créé la surprise sur la
polynormande alors qu'il était stagiaire
professionnel c'était à l'été 2010 9
il était parvenu à monter sur le podium
ce jour-là de la classique normande qui
se déroule en cours d'été il fait partie
pour l'instant des cinq hommes de tête
et on surveillera les qualités de
puncheur de valentin ferron lorsque la
route s'élèvera de nouveau et celle ci
s'élèvera très régulièrement jusqu'à
l'arrivée
la prise de relais donc ici avec les 4
as autre homme de ce groupe de tête un
groupe de tête dans lequel est bien le
coureur qui a le plus de références on
en parlait tout à l'heure c'est
peut-être le transalpin alessandro
fedeli alors fait des liquides et des
deux véritables capacités de finisseur
c'est un coureur très rapide il a décidé
aujourd'hui de se lancer dans un
scénario au long cours lui qui a déjà
gagné un des sprints massifs
alessandro fedeli notamment sur le tour
de croatie sur le tour du rwanda il
avait gagné également une belle étape
l'année dernière sur le tour du limousin
qui est une course à difficile donc
preuve que ce n'est pas seulement un
sprinteur stoïciens un coureur
passe-partout qui sera peut-être
l'élément clé à suivre jérémy dans ce
groupe de cinq coureurs d'expérience
comme vous l'avez très bien dit l'an
passé il a remporté une très belle
victoire d'étape sur le tour du limousin
devant rui costa
cet accord qui c'est qui sait mener à
bien des échappées qui esquissaient être
offensif et qui a une bonne bonne
explosivité sûr c'est sur ces finales de
course casse pattes on l'a forcément sur
une échappée au long cours avec un vent
défavorable il faut être vigilant a pas
trop pas trop s'user avant ce final
avant de pouvoir se livrer à 200%
on rappelle donc 22 formations au départ
de cette course pour cette troisième
manche de la coupe de france
professionnel et l'apparition ce matin
au départ d'une d'une équipe world tour
une pro team c'est l'appellation
officielle avec cette équipe intermarché
wanty gaubert matériaux à qui se
présente au départ c'est l'équipe la
mieux classée en termes de division
mondiale est un homme à l'intérieur de
celle-ci sera l'un des favoris à
l'italien andrea pascual n 1 qu'elle
inquiète un sprinteur de niveau de
valeur mondiale à qui a déjà brillé sur
des courses internationales andrea
pasqua l'one qui a disputé le tour de
france et les plus belles courses du
calendrier
pasqua l'homme pourrait être et bien un
adversaire 1 pour arnaud démare pour
nacer bouhanni ou encore un pour niccolo
bonifacio également l'italien neutre
italien celui de la formation total
direct energie
bref la liste est longue la liste est
non exhaustive des coureurs qui 1 1
pourrait briller en cas d'arrivée
massive mais ce final va nous permettre
d'en savoir plus un final et qui
pourrait convenir également aux
puncheurs avec elle
nombre d'ascensions qui est assez
important dans les 40 derniers
kilomètres notamment vrai on pourrait
rajouter d'autres italiens avec simonet
qu'on sony ou attilio viviani de
l'équipe cofidis
quel petit frère un délit a tout à fait
et qui avait remporté une course en
étant stagiaires qu'il avait permis de
signer son contrat professionnel chez
cofidis donc encore de bons coureurs
rapides en cas de sprint massif ouais
simonet comme sony également inquiète un
coureur relativement jeune lui aussi un
progrès saison après saison il était
arrivé pour rentrer dans le train des
lits à viviani 1 du côté de la formation
cofidis et peu à peu il est en train de
se faire une place les été alignés
aujourd'hui en position de leader avec
le dossard 31 simonet comme sony qui
nous vient de la piste je crois un cab
et briller dans les catégories de jeunes
au niveau mondial sur piste
un autre italien également jérémy un
petit peu moins connu c'est damiano
ccima le coureur de gazprom russe vélo
qui a lui a la particularité d'avoir
déjà gagné sur un grand tour ans il a
gagné une étape sur le tour d'italie
notamment pour cette formation russe
avec qui elle se déplace avec également
sept coureurs sept coureurs c'est le
maximum autorisé par par équipes 1 sur 7
courses d'un jour et avant c'était huit
coureurs effectivement selon le
règlement mais depuis depuis deux
saisons maintenant il ya un courant -
par par équipes sur les courses donc le
passage s'est fait de huit à sept
coureurs pour les courses d'une journée
où les courses à étapes normales on va
dire et sur les grands tours fait passer
de neuf coureurs à 8
le dernier carré est tombé 1 2 minutes
on va faire court jérémy est ce que
cette échappée a des chances aujourd'hui
d'aller au bout quel est votre sentiment
alors qu'on est encore à 85 kilomètres
de l'arrivée 2 minutes 35 l'écart entre
l'échappée et le peloton non on peut
voir que le peloton gère gère
parfaitement même s'il ya une équipe où
il n'est qu'une équipe et demi aurait
dès qu'ils auront l'envié que deux
coureurs qui est qu'ils chassent
vraiment tout est sous contrôle
actuellement il ya très peu de chances
que cette échappée aille au bout mais
par contre
on va s'intéresser au déroulement de la
suite du scénario savoir si la course va
se durcir assez loin de l'arrivée avec
pas mal d'offensives parce que les
équipes vont pas laisser forcément vrai
l'équipe intermarché ou en ti gaubert et
l'équipe groupama fdj pour favoriser un
sprint massif et sont là aussi pour
durcir et est allé chercher une victoire
et il ya possibilité dans ce final
casse-pattes ouvert un peu à tout vent
et et à tout le monde ouais puis il ya
aussi des équipes effectivement qui
n'ont pas de véritables sprinteurs au
départ de la course je pense là à une
autre équipe française qui nous vient de
la bretagne c'est bnb hôtels acquis 1 se
déplace avec de nombreux pêcheurs voir
des grimpeurs qui sont en phase de
reprise c'est le cas de pierre rolland
avec est l'un des grands noms de ceux le
ton de la roue tourangelle qui a
effectué sa reprise dimanche dernier du
côté de cholet pays de loire et qui sort
d'un stage assez intense avec ses
coéquipiers dont maxime chevalier cette
sas est une équipe par exemple qui est
là pour contrarier les plans des
formations de sprinteurs avec évidemment
le tourangeau jonathan hivert oui à n'en
pas douter seront là pour pour dynamiter
ce final effectivement jonathan hivert
et sur ses terres il à domicile
il connaît les routes par coeur je pense
qu'on pourra le voir à passer à
l'offensive
présent lors dans leur équipe ils ont
malgré tout un ce prime à un cours qui
va assez vite au sprint en l'occurrence
encore un italien le cas maud bateaux
bloqués mods atoki à sera bien servi
également avec kévin reza qui sera là
pour l'appuyer dans le final mais c'est
vrai que face à arnaud démare à nacer
bouhanni à nicolo bonifacio
eh bien peut-être que cette équipe
anticipera également dans les 40
derniers kilomètres
ce sera l'un à des enjeux toujours
est-il bien que les coureurs se
rapproche de sainte maure de touraine où
ils vont passer une deuxième fois cet
après midi après le départ qui a été
donné à 12 heures 12 heures 15
en ce qui concerne le départ réel et je
pense que le peloton ne se rapproche un
n'est plus très loin maintenant de cette
localité de 2 des peurs on rappelle pour
l'instant et que l'écart est toujours
supérieure aux 2 minutes 30
il reste 85 km et les coureurs qui
évoluent
des routes plutôt étroites ça ce sera le
fil rouge un de l'après midi avec des
routes assez sinueuse 1 du côté de
l'indre et loire
j'irai qu'ici pour l'instant c'est assez
large mais ça devrait se rendre encore
plus étroits tout à l'heure notamment
dans les 40 derniers kilomètres
oui pas mal d'alternance entre des
routes étroites sinueuses et les routes
un peu plus praticable plus large pour
que les véhicules puissent doublé c'est
une particularité aussi cette course
parce que l'organisateur souhaite rendre
hommage à tous les villages et des
communautés de communes qui sont
traversés qui sont partenaires de cette
épreuve donc voilà il se donne en ligne
directrice de rejoindre tous ces
villages donc des fois c'est par des
petites routes de campagne
oui la communauté de communes touraine
val de vienne avec cette grande boucle
dans le sud touraine 125 km c'est le
menu de la 1re partie en quelque sorte
de cette course 1 125 km avant de
remonter ensuite vers les bords de la
loire tout à l'heure et les bords du
cher puisque le final est conforme
toutes les années un tous les ans on a
le même final sur la roue tourangelle ça
c'est un repère important pour les
coureurs
la ville de départ change le parcours
change inévitablement mais c'est 40
derniers kilomètres cela eux ne bougent
pas et c'est peut-être dans cette
dernière heure que va s'écrire
évidemment les plus grandes lignes à de
la 19ème édition avec un enchaînement
d'ascension et qui permettra aux
puncheurs est bien de d'essayer de
surprendre les sprinteurs et notamment
les deux dernières montées la côte rude
et carlo et à la côte de l'epan ça c'est
un nom à qui vous parle forcément la
côte de l'epan avec avait été un le juge
de paix également pendant quelques
années de paris tours qui est l'autre
grande course cycliste et professionnels
qui se termine à quelques hectomètres
dc1 seulement jérémy effectivement fait
un boulevard à la perpendiculaire l'art
est fait par ifs lourd par rapport au
boulevard jean royer l'avenue grand mont
houy
la montée de la rue de l'epan c'était un
stack classique pour se parer tour qui
s'est redessiné qui c'est qui sera
inscrit dans une nouvelle nouvelle
histoire maintenant en traversant les
chemins de vignes sur une partie plus au
nord de la loire qui aura lieu donc au
mois d'octobre qui est devenue une autre
classique finalement la classique des
feuilles mortes s'est transformé en un
classique des feuilles de vigne 1 pour
son appellation officieuse les coureurs
donc se poursuivre leur route
e donc dans les 80 derniers kilomètres
ou presque avec un les cinq hommes de
tête dont on rappelle l'identité il y à
dylan kowalski le coureur de sélys à
roubaix lille métropole le dossard 192
que l'on aperçoit ici sur la gauche de
l'image maintenant en dernière position
kowalski qui a fait son retour chez les
professionnels alors il a plusieurs
carrières un guy lannes il est
redescendu amateurs avant finalement est
bien l approche de la trentaine de
retrouver les grands est un courant de
talent et est d'ailleurs sa formation
nordiste compte beaucoup sur lui en ce
début de saison parce qu'il est
particulièrement en forme wii est
d'ailleurs retourné dans l'équipe qui
l'avait fait passer professionnel à
l'époque c'était l'équipe roubaix
maintenant c'est qu'ils élisent trouvé
voilà deux saisons là-bas suivi de
malheureusement trois saisons chez les
amateurs mais il a réussi à prouver
qu'il avait le potentiel qu'il avait
encore l' envie de briller chez les
professionnels et cerexhe
c'est bien le retrouver à l'avant
aujourd'hui ça prouve que son équipe a
fait un bon choix de le recruter cet
hiver et il frôle il prouve tout
simplement qu'il a le niveau de
l'échelon professionnel
c'est totalement re motiver remis en
question dylan kowalski qui avait même
pensé stopper le vélo 1 fut un temps il
y a quelques années de cela et puis il
s'est reconstruit un physique une
motivation du côté de l'équipe côtes
d'armor la formation amateur avant de
rejoindre celle du vc rouen et donc de
repasser professionnels et grâce à de
belles performances notamment en classe
2 sur des courses comme le tour de
normandie ou encore sur la ronde de
l'oise
dylan kowalski qui participe pour la
première fois à la roue tourangelle il
est accompagné donc en tête à paris
martine uriane stade le norvégien qui
n'est autre que le champion de norvège
espoir
ça c'est un titre qui compte puisqu'on
le sait un la norvège est un qu'une
nation qui à chaque année révèle bien
des talents jérémy vous avez couru avec
de nombreux norvégiens dans le peloton
il y en a encore beaucoup et ça c'est
une vraie référence
c'est sûr que champion de norvège
espoirs safa signe un petit peu son
coureur on va dire c'est que la norvège
est quand même réputé pour avoir des
très bons coureurs des bons rouleurs
aussi donc on peut s'attendre à ce que
ce cours soit un élément solide de
s'être échappé même si il reste assez
jeune fait un titre espoirs qui va qu'il
a conquis l'an passé jérémy on retrouve
les coureurs justement du côté de sainte
maure de touraine ils vont passer à
l'endroit où ils ont été présentés ce
matin à l'occasion du départ ici sur la
place
un départ qui a été donné à 12 heures
une première boucle bouclée 125 km déjà
dans les jambes sous le soleil certes
mais des kilomètres qui s'accumulent
ainsi une course qui est longue qui va
dépasser les 200 km et tous les coureurs
ne sont pas à la même enseigne
finalement en ce début de saison
certains ont eu la chance de courir à
deux manières régulièrement certains à
sont en son talent à leur course de
reprise 1 il y en a une dizaine qui
accumulent leurs premiers kilomètres ici
sur les routes de touraine
c'est sûr que les corps qui ont pu faire
une ou deux belles courses à étapes
avant de courir cette roue tourangelle
vont avoir un avantage je pense
notamment à ceux qui on peut courir
paris-nice ou le tour de catalogne
récemment par rapport à des coureurs qui
sont en reprise c'est sûr que pour pour
durer sur la distance sur les 204 km ça
aura son importance dans le final est
d'ailleurs andrea pasqua lan dont on
parlait tout à l'heure dans ce peloton
de la roue tourangelle est celui qui a
le plus couru depuis le début de la
saison avec déjà plus de 3000 km dans
les jambes en compétition bien sûr parce
que à l'entraînement les kilomètres sont
tout autres jérémy justement on aborde
le mois d'avril le quatrième mois de
l'année petite indication comme ça on a
combien de kilomètres dans les jambes
ans en avril
quand on est coureur professionnel
une bonne question ça dépend des
objectifs de chacun
ça dépend du nombre de jours de course
parcouru aussi mais on on peut se baser
sur sur sept huit mille kilomètres après
un hiver effectivement assez copieux à
retirer à partir du 1er janvier à partir
du 1er janvier certes à pour les
coureurs professionnels présents sur la
roue tourangelle mais certains
effectivement dans ces moments sont pas
à ce stade là certains ont des objectifs
plus lointains
un calendrier qui c'est qui s'est
divisée évidemment puisque aujourd'hui
on parle de spécialisation on parle le
pic de forme bref il faut localiser tous
ses temps forts dans une saison et tous
les coureurs n'ont pas le même
calendrier préétabli en début d'année
les coureurs ont quitté donc
sainte-maure-de-touraine 1 place
maintenant à la remontée là il ya un
changement de direction à cet endroit là
puisque bien remonte vers le nord
voilà c'est fait on enfin on pourra voir
que les coureurs vont vendre côté le
vent qui viendra de la droite
voilà il y aura peut-être pas de
bordures parce que le vent pour europe
propice pour les bordures sera un vent
trois quarts dos mais par contre ça va
quand même durcir la course puisque tout
le peloton sera exposée donc on pourra
avoir un peloton en file indienne
malgré tout donc à une course qui va
commencer à se durcir
ouais des passages assez piégeux on le
voit ici à l'image des passages
complètement découvert sur ce faux plat
montant et il y en aura quelques uns des
passages comme cela je n'attends hiver à
témoigner dans la nouvelle république un
peu avant la course effectivement que le
secteur autour des localités de deuil de
fil n également sera exposée pourra être
sujet deux temps forts dans cette course
mais voilà tout cela dépend de la
physionomie de la course pour le moment
on est encore en position d'attenté avec
cette échappée ce peloton un schéma
assez classique
est ce qu'il y a un intérêt pour le
peloton de tenter quelque chose à cet
endroit là là est la question
pas pour les équipes qui roulent en tête
qui sont qui sont là pour provoquer un
sprint massif plus pour les autres
équipes qui sont en face d'attentes de
tenter des choses pour durcir pour faire
perdre des équipiers aux équipes qui
roule
c'est des moments comme ça qui sont
favorables pour vraiment durcir éliminer
quelques concurrents les coureurs qui
aborderont tout à l'heure le quatrième
classement du meilleur grimpeur du côté
de saintes et en 1 3 ont déjà été
disputées pour l'instant et bien c'est
le coureur suisse de cette échappée qui
a comptabilisé le plus de points celui
qui passe on relaie ici en première
position en la personne de thé richir
qu'est le coureur l'un des coureurs les
plus expérimentés de ce groupe de tête
il a 28 ans il participe pour la
deuxième fois à cette course qu'il
connaît donc un petit peu s'il a
quelques souvenirs lui qui est un
rouleur un médaillé sur les championnats
de suisse du contre-la-montre à
plusieurs reprises il a pris pour
l'instant à deux reprises les plus gros
points au sommet de ses montées
répertorier ces montées qui ne sont
jamais très longue
aujourd'hui sur le parcours mais avec
tout de même quelques pourcentages
quelques raids art comme on dit dans le
jargon
elles sont proposées aux coureurs
d'entre eux sont répertoriés monde en
dénombre une petite trentaine ici et là
sur le circuit de la roue tourangelle
le peloton qui suit à son cours
évidemment ne s'affole pas pour le
moment un peloton qui ne roulent pas à
son rythme le plus intense ça va monter
en régime ça va monter en pression dans
les kilomètres à venir et c'est pour
l'instant elle toujours là groupama fdj
qui assure le tempo
l'équipe groupama fdj emmenés par un
thierry bricaud à la direction sportive
cet après midi qui a se déplace avec une
équipe évidemment conquérante une équipe
très expérimentée pour conduire le
sprint arnaud démare on parle de
l'équipe groupama fdj comme l'un des
trains les plus puissants sur la planète
cyclisme depuis maintenant et j'ai bien
quelques saisons c'est encore plus vrai
depuis l'année 2000 vain puisque arnaud
démare a été le sprinteur le plus
prolifique
ça change et ça change les choses au
sein de la formation de marc madiot de
s'appuyer sur un train aussi efficace
que celui là oui c'est un frein qui
s'est construit avec le temps c'était
une volonté va d'arnaud une volonté de
l'équipe de tout mettre en oeuvre pour
pouvoir avoir les meilleures
dispositions pour appréhender un sprint
c'est une chose qui est qui a été voilà
qui était bien travaillé c'est pas
évident aussi de s'organiser entre
équipiers d'avoir chacun sa place chacun
confiance en l'autre et ils ont su le
prouver voilà l'an dernier c'est sûr que
le train mis en place et les résultats
qui en ont découlé ont prouvé que qu'ils
étaient qu'ils étaient là bien
fonctionnel vont cette année le train a
moins bien fonctionné donc ils sont en
phase de papa de rodage mais deux
de reprise de confiance pour cette
saison une reprise de repères qui
passera peut-être par la roue
tourangelle
on rappelle un la composition de cette
équipe et de ce train qui a sera chargé
d'emmener tout à l'heure arnaud démare
avec un le lituanien konovalovas ce le
néerlandais sinkeldam est également
l'italien à guarne riz sans oublier
benjamin thomas l'un des meilleurs
rouleurs français du moment également
benjamin thomas qui a lui aussi un va
mettre à contribution ses qualités pour
étirer le peloton dans les derniers
instants de course mais avant cela il
faudra passer les nombreuses montées à
que compte cette roue tourangelle a
démonté mais pas seulement puisqu'il y
aura également un secteur pavé tout à
l'heure et oui nous sommes dans une
paire dans une période de classiques
flandriennes de classiques pavées alors
alors certes il n'y aura pas de
paris-roubaix dans une semaine mais il y
aura bel et bien un secteur pavé sur les
routes de d'indre-et-loire tout à
l'heure un secteur qui sera relativement
court 1 qui ne devrait pas faire
basculer la course mais attention quand
même
oui c'est un secteur qui fait du 1 km
mais il va précéder une belle difficulté
à villandry juste à côté du château
c'est un endroit peut-être que quelques
touristes le connaît c'est un endroit
clé de la loire à vélo qui a fait un
passage à un petit peu mythique mais cet
endroit l'an passé il ya deux ans par
dont c'était la première fois que la
roue tourangelle y passer savez savez
quand même bien étirer le peloton avant
d'enchaîner ce final oui c'est un petit
peu le début un de ce grand final il
reste à cet endroit
une petite trentaine de kilomètres et
effectivement il faut commencer à jouer
placé
avant de tourner sur la droite un pour
aller chercher les premiers coteaux et
les monter un final qui 1 promet bien
des choses la tête de peloton emmené
également par un coureur de l'équipe
intermarché ou en petits gaubert
matériaux une équipe qui s'appuiera sur
andrea pasqua bonne équipe qui est venue
avec six éléments au départ de l'épreuve
dont un français assez jérémy bellicaud
à inquiéter qui s'était révélé avec le
cc etupes lorsqu'il était amateur et
jérémy bellicaud l'un des bons puncheurs
grimpeurs également que compte la
génération montante française en matière
de cyclisme l'équipe intermarché ou anti
gaubert qui a obligé tout à l'heure et
l'une des seules formations pro team a
au même titre que les équipes françaises
bien sûr groupama fdj ou encore ag2r
citroën et à la formation à cofidis
notamment qui figure dans la première
division 1 mondial alors avons nous un
nouvel écart c'est la question qu'on se
pose actuellement un nouvel écart
peut-être entre les hommes de tête est
là et le peloton 2 minutes 15 pour les 5
fuyards deux minutes et quinze secondes
seulement jérémy ça continue de diminuer
sur une allure assez constant depuis le
départ de l'épreuve
oui férec fut une diminution progressive
un petit rouleau compresseur qui
s'installe et derrière avec un peloton
qui avancent sereinement mais voilà qui
maintenant ne les fera plus pu partir
l'échappée plus de temps d' avance et
voilà une échappée presque presque
condamnés mais voilà qui va pas baisser
les bras non plus hein ils savent qu'il
faut atteindre ses bords du cher ses
bords de loire pour pour se livrer à
fond
voilà ils ont un petit espoir en tête
encore de faire vivre cette échappée
voilà je peux maintenant ce sera le
peloton qui décidera de l'endroit où il
accélérera pour aller chercher et
cueillir cette échappée oui mais oui
mais attention à ce final 1 c'est
sinueux avec un ses nombreux lacets ces
quelques côtes où il ya assez peu de
repères un pour le peloton finalement un
peloton dans les 40 derniers kilomètres
qui verra très très peu les échappées 1
ça tournicote beaucoup et les attaquants
sont souvent récompensés
il ya deux ans on pensait que l'échappée
se ferait rattraper effectivement mai
ils ont réussi à tenir à se relancer
dans ce final justement pour maintenir
quelques secondes sur la ligne d'arrivée
ont certes il avait eu un peu plus
d'avancé au cours de l'épreuve avec plus
de 7 minutes
mais voilà contre toute attente il avait
pu résister jusqu'au bout
ouais sur le papier ce n'est pas en la
faveur des hommes de tête mais qui sait
le vélo nous apportent parfois quelques
surprises il faut évidemment prendre en
compte les caractéristiques du parcours
un parcours pour un homme fort un
parcours pour attaquons cet après midi
même si les sprinteurs ont généralement
le dernier mot il y a de la place pour
essayer de surprendre le peloton et les
échappés vont tout faire pour résister
le plus longtemps possible avec deux
coureurs français dylan kowalski et
valentin ferron un orthézien martin lui
rien stade théry schir représente la
formation swiss racing academy et puis
aller sans de reflets delhi représente
les chances italiennes
il porte les couleurs d'une équipe
française le team delko voilà pour cette
échappée à cinq le peloton donc navigue
désormais un peu plus de deux minutes
des hommes de tête un écart qui diminue
mais qui pourrait remonter un également
tout à l'heure parce qu'on joue
généralement aussi loin de l'arrivée on
joue toujours un petit peu au chat et à
la souris
un écart qui fait le yoyo entre
l'échappée et le peloton
oui oui bien sûr comme d'habitude si le
peloton se rapproche trop rapidement de
l'échappée ce faire rien de rattraper
l'échappée dès maintenant au risque
d'ouvrir des brèches pour pour se faire
attaquer donc
la position idéale pour ces équipes qui
souhaitent un sprint massif
effectivement cessé d'attendre le plus
longtemps possible pour pour aller
chercher cette échappée mais tout en la
maintenant à portée de fusil donc c'est
tout l'enjeu 6 6 devant ils ralentissent
de trop si l'échappée ralentit trop le
peloton ralentir a également cédé des
coûts stratégiques un d'efforts on a vu
des échappées vraiment su relever jouer
et pour pouvoir repartir à fond derrière
et résister jusqu'au bout c'est des
petites stratégies voilà qu'il faut
mettre en place et à tester y avait un
coureur spécialistes que vous avez
beaucoup côtoyé dans les échappées
c'était évidemment thomas voeckler a
inquiété en quelque sorte le spécialiste
dans ce jeu là et qu'ils savaient freiné
parce qu'il savait pertinemment que le
peloton ne roulerait pas plus vite que
lui pour mieux en garder dans le dans le
final a exactement c'est tout à fait ce
profil que thomas avait de gérer son
échappée de pas forcément se livrer à
100 % et d'attendre le vraiment le
moment propice pour pourrait accélérer
et c'est vrai qu'ils gênaient pas de
vraiment de ralentir pour que peut-on
ralentissent et qu'il s'économise au
maximum à jérémy roy qui lançait un
rayon comptant par l'échappée évidemment
des échappées qui ont marqué votre
carrière à part seulement pas seulement
des échappées mais j'irai vous étiez
très souvent à l'avant notamment en
première partie de carrière avec
notamment ce titre de super combatif du
tour de france c'était il ya déjà dix
ans en 2011
je me trompe si en deuxième partie de
carrière il ya eu peut-être l'effet
thibaut pinot qui est rentré dans votre
vie personnelle et professionnelle
puisque vous l'avez ensuite beaucoup
accompagné voyons c'est tout à fait ça
ma première partie de carrière j'étais
plutôt livre mes actions donc jeté à
corps offensive donc c'est vrai que je
me faisais plaisir dans prenant pas mal
d'échapper ci m'a permis aussi de
remporter quelques quelques épreuves
puis en seconde partie de carrière ça
que j'ai eu l'opportunité d'accompagner
thibault thibaut pinot sûr
bastien sur sa progression de carrière
des jeux les vues passer néo
professionnel dans l'équipe fdj à
l'époque
voilà j'ai eu la chance aussi de la
compagne est presque gagnée par
procuration d'atteindre ce niveau là
c'était une chose que je n'avais jamais
connu avec mes leaders et coéquipier de
l'époque donc c'est voilà c'est une
deuxième partie de carrière que je que
je regarde pas du tout je ne suis pas
j'étais pas cantonnée au seul fait de
faire des attaques alors gagné par
procuration c'est une belle expression
et me revient en tête évidemment
l'émotion que vous partagiez au bord de
la route pour votre dernière course en
ligne chez les professionnels c'était le
tour de lombardie le monument gagné par
à thibaut pinot en italie on vous voit
donc en toute fin de saison sur le bord
de la route après avoir abattu un
travail considérable dans cette course
là exulté à quelques hectomètres de
l'arrivée 1 ces grandes émotions
oui grande émotion ac c'est une chose
assez exceptionnelle de pouvoir et faire
la course
rouler j'ai dû faire 180 kilomètres en
tête de peloton pour pour contrôler une
échappée justement et pouvoir pouvoir
prendre un raccourci pour rejoindre
l'arrivée et voir la ville trafic
thibaut pinot donc fait tous les astres
étaient alignés aujourd'hui on parlait
plus cette époque on parlait de thomas
voeckler tout à l'heure que vous aviez
battu justement dans votre carrière sur
paris nice à une victoire d'étape en
2009 du côté de l'ardèche à vallon pont
d'arc dans un mano a mano dans le final
1 contre contre thomas voeckler vous
étiez dans la toute première partie de
votre carrière ça faisait quelques
années que vous étiez promet à ce moment
là vous êtes un véritable grand espoir
du cyclisme français jérémy victoire
assure le grand prix la marseillaise sur
le tro bro leon
j'ai eu quelques très belles saisons à
notamment à 2009 2010 2011
oui tout à fait c'était un peu le pic de
ma carrière à titre personnel au niveau
résultat personnel
voilà je suis satisfait de ma carrière
on prend le temps évidemment parce qu'on
a quelques quelques dizaines de minutes
encore deux petites heures avant l
arrivée de cette édition de la roue
tourangelle c'est un plaisir donc de
pouvoir être accompagné aujourd'hui par
gm
gethin un tourangeau pure souche
évidemment et keanu contrat tout à
l'heure et bien la prestation de ses
attaquants du côté de la roue
tourangelle troisième manche de la coupe
de france
fdj la coupe de france professionnelle
de cyclisme et la 19e édition également
par la même occasion de cette épreuve
alors allé chercher un nouveau
classement grimpeur donc là ça va être
intéressant de voir si scheer va
continuer à engranger les points ou 6
kowalski qui était tellement deuxième va
essayer de repasser devant
alors scheer et non pas cher à qui il
est arrivé quelques bricoles sur une
autre course
en ce dimanche après midi vous êtes
peut-être un déjà au courant avec les
nouvelles règles dictées par un parent
lui c'est y qui est entré en vigueur il
ya quelques jours seulement
oui secours a été mis hors course pour
un g 2 billions
voilà les jets de bidons ne sont plus
autorisés du tout là il l'avait jetée
auprès de spectateurs alors est ce que
c'est ça qui la pose problème puisque le
jets de bidons
il n'y a plus le droit de donner un
bidon un spectateur sait ce que c'est ce
que signifie cette règle c'est ça c'est
le jets de bidons
oui j'ai deux bidons en général à
n'importe où et puis encore plus dans sa
période de covile auprès des spectateurs
voilà tant que ça c'est s'agit de
michael schaer inquiété à sanctionner
tout à l'heure sur le tour des flandres
qui est notre épreuve évidemment que
l'on en suit cet après-midi en matière
de cyclisme toujours les couleurs bleue
blanche et rouge les couleurs tricolores
d'arnaud démare mais aussi les couleurs
de la tunisie groupe fdj qui sont aussi
les couleurs de total direct énergie
qu'on aperçoit juste à côté une équipe
total direct energie qui se présente
avec son sprinteur italien nicolo
bonifacio
l'homme venu du de lombardie et du
piémont me semble-t-il nicolau bonifacio
à quelques kilomètres de la frontière
française qui fait équipe avec un autre
local puisque dans cette formation se
présente également marlon gaillard on a
évoqué jonathan hivert tout à l'heure
marlon gaillard et l'autre régional de
l'étape 1 ce matin lui qui découvre la
roue tourangelle à l'occasion de cette
édition 2021 originaire de chinon la
course et adhère traverser la ville de
chinon que le coureur tourangeau
également même si là il
la fée sa partie amateur dans un club
d'un autre département puis a vendu pour
sa partie espoir mais l'accord qui doit
avoir vraiment plaisir à rouler sur ces
routes qu'il connaît également par coeur
chinon qui était aussi la ville départ
de cette course il y a quelques années
de cela c'était de mémoire justement il
ya deux ans lors de l'édition précédente
l'édition 2019
les coureurs s'est élancé depuis la
localité est 2 chine on découvre
toujours dans des passages assez piégeux
1 s'est découvert où le vent peut
s'engouffrer
mais pour le moment le scénario suit son
cours avec une échappée de cinq hommes
cinq unités qui sont devant
depuis le 15e kilomètre de la course
déjà et oui déjà plus de son kilomètres
d'échappée pour les cinq échappés les
cinq hommes de tête et qui possédait
tout à l'heure 2 minutes 15 d'avancé sur
le peloton
on aura probablement à de nouvelles
informations à venir concernant cet
écart entre les deux parties de la
course lors à noter quelques coureurs
qui ont mis le clignotant dans cette
première partie trois coureurs ne sont
déjà plus dans le dans le peloton et
parmi ceux là il ya notamment un coureur
français jérémie est allé samuel l'euro
de l'équipe que j'ai dix roubaix lille
métropole qui a dû malheureusement
abandonné il ya aussi également un
coureur espagnol adria moreno salah de
l'équipe vorarlberg et le coureur
canadien adam devos de l'équipe rallye
faille kling adria moreno salah que la
france connaît également parce qu'il
apportait encore l'an passé les couleurs
de l'avc aix en provence il avait été
l'un des meilleurs amateurs sur le
calendrier national français l'année
dernière est lui qui a retrouvé donc une
place chez les professionnels au sein de
cette continental autrichienne le team
bord halberg que l'on connaît bien
puisque c'est une équipe qui roule
régulièrement sur les circuits de la
coupe de france
c'est vrai que ce sont généralement les
mêmes équipes qui sont invités qui
affronte acte de candidature dans un
premier temps avant d'être retenu on aa
très régulièrement
le team bourg halberg à l'équipe rallye
cycling par exemple la formation
amérique
n mais également les suisses de swiss
racing
on a également une rixe pro cycling team
les norvégiens qui seront à suivre avec
une information qui progresse saison
après saison
la gazprom russe vélo représentons la
russie la formation caja rural également
pour l'espagne le team burgos en dro
nick giocattoli si des remèdes pour
l'italie qui s'est déplacé avec cinq
coureurs et puis à sans oublier
également les coureurs belges avec un la
formation sport vlaanderen bâloise ou
encore l'équipe bingo wallonie bruxelles
l'équipe bing gaulle qui est aussi la
formation tenant du titre depuis la
victoire de lionel taminiaux il y a deux
ans on n'a pas pu voir malheureusement
le passage au sommet de la bosse tout à
l'heure on vous tiendra informés de la
suite de des hostilités avec le
classement actualisé classement des
meilleurs grimpeurs qui est baptisé le
grand prix des châteaux ici sur la roue
tourangelle
alors justement je crois qu'on en sait
un peu plus un depuis quelques instants
martin ne rien stats a pris la première
place donc au 4e classement du meilleur
grimpeur du côté de la montée en
direction de santé pan il est passé à
devant le suisse achir et le 3e valentin
ferron ça se resserre dans ce classement
il durera à match jusqu'au bout mais il
va falloir résister un évidement
résister au retour du peloton pour
espérer marquer des points
supplémentaires
tiens les chiffres semblent bien partis
quand même pour aller chercher ce
classement de la montagne
enfin de la montagne des châteaux tout
est relatif puisque l'altitude la plus
importante aujourd'hui dépasse tout
juste les 100 m c'est un département
assez plat l'indre et loire mais mal
placé luxe près l'expression que vous
utilisiez tout à l'heure
on peut grimper un également très bien
depuis le niveau de la mer avec des
montées courtes certes mais qui seront
assez raide également on s'en apercevra
tout à l'heure oui tout à fait les
petits coteaux le petit coteau du cher
les petits coteaux de la loire montée
assez courte mais assez pentue des
montées assez punchy avec des passages à
10 % par endroits ce sera le cas
notamment dans les deux dernières
montées tout à l'heure lorsque les
coureurs seront à temps très dans les 15
derniers kilomètres ça va être
passionnant à suivre ce final explosif
final nerveux en prévision ici à du côté
de tours le boulevard jean royer qui
attend le peloton professionnel tout à
l'heure pour cette édition un acquis 1
avait subi à une petite absence d'une
année en 2020 1 pour cause de pandémie
mondiale avant de faire son retour
c'était compliqué hein de mettre cette
épreuve sur pied tout le monde connaît
évidemment le contexte sanitaire qui est
celui de la france actuellement et on
peut d'autant plus tirer notre coup de
chapeau à tirer notre chapeau à bernard
mâchefers et toute son équipe qui a su
résister un dans ces derniers jours
assez difficile avec évidemment un les
actes et les accords politiques pour
permettre au peloton de s'élancer on
peut que leur tirer notre notre énorme
coup de chapeau
j'ai assisté hier à la réunion des
directeurs sportifs et je peux vous dire
que bernard mâchefers était vraiment ému
quand il a quand il a lancé cette
réunion il a fait un petit rappel de
l'historique des problématiques liées
lyoko vide
c était vraiment ému qu'il a ouvert il a
lâché sa petite larme et on peut on peut
que le féliciter et toute son équipe
quand je vois le nombre de bénévoles qui
sont qui sont en place sur le terrain
vraiment un coup de chapeau à lui et ses
équipes mais aussi à tous ces petits
organisateurs qui oeuvrent toute l'année
pour pour faire ses courses pour pour
créer des courses pour les maintenir en
vie pour aller chercher des partenaires
voire les autorisations de traverser
dans les villes qui se battent pour
essayer d'accueillir les équipes dans
les meilleures conditions donc c'est
vraiment c'est eux qui font vivre que
ces coupes de france se sert et voilà
c'est tout simplement merci bravo et
continuez
ouais merci pour le cyclisme est
évidemment bernard mâchefers et toute
son équipe qui n ont pas dû dormir
beaucoup un ces derniers jours et ces
dernières nuits mais la récompense est
là avec ce soleil alors certes le départ
et l'arrivée sont organisées à huis clos
aujourd'hui mais tout de même et bien
tout au long du parcours on retrouvera
quelques spectateurs ici et là elle qui
apprendront toutes les précautions qui
s'imposent évidemment pour saluer les
coureurs et surtout l'important est bien
c'est que le cyclisme persiste que le
peloton professionnel puisse continuer
donc à s'exprimer dans de bonnes
conditions et c'est le cas sur les
routes de centre val de loire a sur les
routes d'indre et loire et de cette
belle province de la touraine qui
accueille donc la 19e édition et oui
bientôt 20 ans pour cette course de la
roue tourangelle qui a dispose d'un pâle
d'un palmarès de plus en plus éloquent
ces dernières années un palmarès qui a
vu pour dernier vainqueur lionel ta
mignon qui était vainqueur devant robin
carpenter et marc sarreau qui avait pris
la troisième place
on s'en souvient puisque nous avions
moins accompagnés des commentaires les
derniers kilomètres également de ses
coureurs le peloton était revenu très
très près des deux hommes de tête qui
avait fait fait preuve de sang froid en
ce jour là oui c'est un magnifique final
fera qu'on avait tout l'impression que
le peloton allait revenir
mais le peloton s'est désagrégée au fur
et à mesure des montées fille avait pu
d'équipier pour s'enrouler pour faire
rentrer comme on dit un petit peu dans
le jargon du cyclisme et bas aussi
numéro un de ces deux coureurs devant
qui avait su résister et robin cad
carpenter on l'avait retrouvé à l'attack
à plusieurs reprises la suite la suite
de la saison solide rouleur et robin
carpenter qui a un nom de héros de
blockbusters américains mais qui est
encore l'un au départ de la roue
tourangelle avec des indes et des
intentions et des ambitions encore
décuplé on peut l'imaginer lui portent
les couleurs de rallye cycling le
dossard 150 de robin carpenter venu pour
essayer de faire encore mieux on se
souvient également avec il y a trois ans
en 2018 marc sarreau s'était imposé
devant samuel dumoulin et hugo
hofstetter en 2017 le succès de flavien
dassonville dassonville donc qui
s'imposait sur une épreuve qui était
déjà parti depuis sainte maure de
touraine en 2017 samuel dumoulin avait
été vainqueur en 2016 lorenzo manzin en
2015 ou encore angelo tulik un retraité
des pelotons désormais tout comme samuel
dumoulin un gab et gagner l'édition 2014
voilà pour les derniers vainqueurs de
cette épreuve
ça s'active en tête de peloton on a
décidé de commencer à durcir on voit qui
sait plus du tout l'équipe groupama des
gis qui roule c'est l'équipe ag2r
citroën accompagné de l'équipe total
direct energie le l'écart avec les
échappés en train de fondre il passait
une minute 25
voilà la tension qui monte un petit peu
on va atteindre les 60 derniers
kilomètres
donc on peut s'attendre à ce qu'il ya un
petit peu de petit peu de chambardement
un petit peu d' attaque pour l'équipe
total et direct energie surtout bien se
replacer 1 puisqu'ils ont un coût
redevance est pas alors intérêt de
perdre des forces à rouler derrière mais
il semble bien que la course va
s'accélérer avec la tension montant ce
en fait fin d'épreuve et kowalski qui en
faisait quelques étirements la fatigue
se fait sentir et c'est légitime cinq
hommes qui sont en train de se livrer
encore plus maintenant depuis quelques
minutes
des relais un peu plus appuyé on essaie
de a gagné quelques kilomètres heure
supplémentaire puisque le la force vive
du peloton se rapproche un peloton qui
roule toujours dans un dans un mouchoir
de poche qui occupe toujours
largeur de la route preuve que si le
rythme s'est intensifiée il peut encore
monter un du côté du peloton qui a de la
marge de ventes devant lui il peut
monter mais c est un signe aussi qu'il
ya de la tension en fait chacun a peur
enfin envie de se replacer donc cet
effet de chacun va remonter chacun a
peur de prendre un petit coup de vent un
petit courant d'air comme on dit et du
coup ça fait cet effet de masse de
boules et à regarder maintenant c'est de
nouveau l'équipe obama fdj qui reprend
le qui reprend le manche puisque c'était
fait un petit peu débordé par sept par
cette tension soudaine qui était apparu
en tête de peloton donc là bien se
repositionner pour essayer de recontrôle
et les choses et oui beaucoup de
sprinteurs qui dit beaucoup de sprinters
au départ dit aussi beaucoup d'équipés à
venir frotter en tête de peloton c'est
le cas à du côté de l'équipe intermarché
ou un petit gaubert matériaux pour
andrea pascual aune-là groupama fdj on
l'a évoqué avec son sprinteur maison le
champion de france arnaud démare
l'équipe cofidis pour raconter cet après
midi sur six monnaies comme sony ou
encore emmanuel morand également
attention à lui
le jeune coureur français le team ag2r
citroën avec deux éléments marque sa
roue et clément venturini le team total
direct énergie présente au départ un
nicolau bonifacio
le team a requis à samsic avec nacer
bouhanni la formation des locaux avec
pierre barbier notamment dans ses rangs
l'équipe androni giocattoli avec matteo
malucelli gazprom russe vélo avec
damiano ccima et j'en passe
la liste des sprinteurs est assez longue
évidemment si chaque sprinteurs à son
train ça fait beaucoup de monde à cet
effet de masse dans la première partie
du peloton à gare aux accrochages
gare aux chutes dans les minutes qui
vont venir généralement n'y a pas
forcément un train par sprinteurs
souvent c'est plus un poisson pilote qui
est dédié à la bonne bonne mise en place
de son fils
heures c'est rare les équipes totalement
dédié pour favoriser un sprint enfin
surtout pour pour lancer un sprint ce
que c'est quand même des efforts assez
spécifique et c'est pour ça que c'est
dur de créer un vrai train donc souvent
c'est un seul coureur qui est là pour
faire au mieux alors quand on se
présente au départ avec deux sprinteurs
dans son équipe
c'est le cas notamment de la formation
ag2r citroën
comment les ce qu'on appelait les terre
et ciel auparavant qu' on change un
petit peu de couleur avec ses couleurs à
dominante blanche maintenant comment
vont-ils procédé dans le final de la
roue tourangelle est ce qu on a un
élément de réponse avec jérémy roy basse
plusieurs cas de figure soit au briefing
ils se sont mis d'accord
pour % mais donc est ce que marx à
revendre mais clément venturini ou est
ce que clément venturini vent mais marc
sarreau même quand on à l'égo d'un
sprinteur abbas et des discussions de
ces discussions de bus et il faut pas
oublier qu'il ya aussi d'orient godon
qui est là qui une bonne pointe de
vitesse alors que devant il ya une
offensive un e
oui dans cette échéance et valentin
ferron qui effectivement fausse
compagnie à ses anciens partenaires
d'échappée il le sent il le sait le
peloton revient vite le peloton revient
fort
on avançait tout à l'heure une minute et
25 secondes
il semblerait que cet écart continue de
diminuer et valentin ferret on en a que
flair il est parti maintenant un pour
s'isoler à à près de 60 kilomètres de
l'arrivée un oui c'est vrai que ça fait
loin mais bon il a pas trop le choix et
le il est obligé de relancer l'échappée
s'ils sont que le peloton est trop
proche derrière et puis il va aller
chercher aussi à un petit peu de points
et un classement
la cote de ville n 1 c'est ça la côte de
villaines les rochers c'est le cinquième
classement grimpeurs avec le suisse
terry qui est parti juste derrière lui
théry schir le cours en suisse de la
formation du même nom suisse racing
académie il va prendre la deuxième place
il est en train de s'assurer à ce
classement du grand prix des châteaux
pour l'appellation de ce classement
meilleur grimpeur en tout cas une
échappée qui désorganise maintenant à
une échappée qui explose on peut voit
que c'est dur c'est dur pour tout le
monde des petits groupes un peu partout
là dans une portion qui fait mal un faux
plat montant qui ne paie pas de mine
mais qui fait mal aux cuisses
oui finalement terry n'a pas réussi à
rentrer est ce que tu as fait on va
attendre maintenant il a vu qu'il
n'avait pas forcément fait assez la
différence est que derrière ça con ça
commençait à se réorganiser ne risque
pas d'insister de trop j'ai l'impression
on a senti un dylan kowalski en dernière
position à la limite de la rupture
effectivement été un petit peu la
rupture mais il a pu y trouver les
ressources nécessaires pour s'accrocher
malgré tout
alors est-ce qu'ils vont réussir à
s'entendre de nouveau on dit
généralement qu'une échappée bien huilé
lorsqu'elle lorsqu'elle se disloque une
première fois ensuite ne parvient pas à
ne parvient plus à s'entendre
on va très vite en avoir la réponse
toujours est il que c'est peut-être un
premier aveu de faiblesse de cette
échappée qui a décidé de s'attaquer est
loin de l'arrivée à 60km un nouveau
soutien en tête de peloton avec l'équipe
sport vlaanderen bâloise leur sprinteur
ce serait un thomas springer son j'ai
l'impression chez eux
formation un qui a un compte bien sûr
dans ce peloton sport vlaanderen bâloise
qui est là depuis à bien des années
également qui a sorti de nombreux
champions 1 pour les envoyer en première
division mondiale ensuite et qui est une
habituée
là aussi de cette épreuve la roue
tourangelle un thomas springer's qui par
le passé étaient montés sur le podium
notamment du tour de vendée il ya
quelques années et qui sera peut-être un
élément à suivre dans cette équipe
relativement jeune avec beaucoup de
jeunes belges faisant partie de cette
formation une échappée qui s'est
reconstitué maintenant puisque valentin
ferron était finalement repris n'a pas
réussi à creuser l'écart plus que ça sur
sur son attaque
non et puis là pas trop insister par la
suite il attendait peut-être du soutien
essayer d'éliminer les éléments les plus
faibles
finalement s'il attaque qui a accouché
d'une souris avec ce groupe de cinq qui
l'ont toujours en tant que tel le
peloton navigue toujours avec une minute
de retard environ
le thon ou ce succès n'a pas mal
d'équipés maintenant aux avant postes
chacun essaye de se replacer c'est de
prendre les devants pour éviter se faire
piéger puis pour aborder cette dernière
je peux pas dire ligne droite mais
presque ces derniers quarante kilomètres
qui sont le long du cher pour de la
loire et du cher pour voilà pour être
pour être là présent quand les
hostilités vont vont débuter puisque ça
va être un final infernal un
enchaînement de cette difficulté des
petites routes des montée pentue d'aider
certains passages pavés et cette boucle
finale dans tout cas
les pièges peuvent être partout les
coureurs prennent la direction de azay
le rideau ils vont rejoindre tout à
l'heure lignières de touraine et à cet
endroit là ils seront effectivement du
côté du bord de loire pour les 40
derniers kilomètres il leur reste encore
une quinzaine de kilomètres de remonter
vers le nord avant de s'attaquer à la
partie finale un petit peu de
changements c'est vrai en tête de
peloton ça s'anime de plus en plus avec
de la tension sur ces routes assez
sinueuse la remontée de l'équipe total
direct energie également sur la droite
de l'image on aperçoit du côté de la
formation rallye cycling également un
maillot distinctif un si je ne m'abuse
champion du canada le maillot de
champion national du canada c'est la
formation de robin carpenter cette
équipe rallye cycling
l'équipe total direct energie qui vient
se replacer aussi l'équipe bnb équipe
ag2r citroën joue un peu des coudes pour
ce pour se replacer c'est normal 3 c'est
stratégique où les coureurs vont prendre
pendant quelques quelques kilomètres
avant un peu plus favorable donc voilà
protection maximale pour éviter de
prendre un petit coup d'élastiques comme
on dit qui coûte bordure ça peut aller
très vite quand le vent est bien présent
trois quarts dos en quelques quelques
centaines de mètres ça peut exploser de
partout on avait annoncé tout à l'heure
l'abandon de adam devos qui finalement
semble bien présent et donc en tête de
peloton avec son maillot de champion
national du canada à lui qui a emmené
tout à l'heure ce peloton avec des
portions voilà on n'a pas besoin de
grimper
des pourcentages un trop fort quelques
faux plats montants permettent également
de créer la sélection et des faux plats
il y en aura dans cette partie
complètement découverte où le vent
pourrait jouer un rôle même si celui ci
ne le souffle pas très fort cet après
midi il va en tout cas usées encore un
peu plus les organismes
oui je pense que c'est cette portion un
petit peu qu'appréhende le peloton on
peut le voir un fait vraiment a
découvert la la route est large il ya la
possibilité encore de remonter et là on
le voit on a plusieurs équipes sur une
même ligne devant on essaie de remonter
évidemment le coureur protégé aux
avant-postes du peloton avec les bienne
guillotin qui sont également remontés
la formation ag2r citroën team sport
vlaanderen bâloise le team total direct
energie la formation groupama fdj est
également aux toutes premières positions
temporise un petit peu tout le monde
s'est placée tout le monde
enfin la place des coureurs devant leur
convient du coup il lève le pied ils
savent que ça peut plus remonter sur les
côtés à moins de passer dans l'herbe
mais bon un peu risqué la guerre des
positions actuellement un moment
charnière de cette édition de la roue
tourangelle troisième manche de la coupe
de france dont on rappelle avec il y
aura 16 épreuves au calendrier si tout
va bien
seize épreuves au total 2 ont été a déjà
disputé le grand prix la marseillaise
c'était au tout début de saison la
première course européenne remporté de
fort belle manière un par aurélien par
et peintre qui a surpris tout le monde
ce jour-là lui le grimpeur aurélien pas
répandre dont on ignorait la pointe de
vitesse puisqu'il s'est défait ce
jour-là de bryan coquard et de thomas
boudât ce qui n'est pas un mince exploit
et tenant un ce jeune garçon aurélien
paraît peintre promis un un très très
bel avenir qui a abrité récemment au
classement général de paris nice et puis
la deuxième manche du côté de cholet
s'était beaucoup plus récent dimanche
dernier victoire au sprint massif signé
elia viviani elia viviani qui a décidé
de laisser sa place ce dimanche à son
petit frère attilio et puis à la coupe
de france se poursuivra également ses
prochaines semaines ces prochains mois
avec un beaucoup d'épreuves qui a se
dérouleront jusqu'au mois d'octobre des
finales
annoncé du côté du tour de vendée mais
également sur la classique du morbihan
bref on aura l'occasion d'en reparler
dans les semaines à venir il y aura un
bel enchaînement en octobre avec déjà
quelques reports connu la route adélie
de vitré qui aura lieu le vendredi 1er
octobre la classic loire atlantique le 2
octobre
et puis un deux trois épreuves
effectivement pour clôturer cette coupe
de france 2021 je reviens sur elia
viviani qui devaient être présents
malgré tout mais
il a chuté cette semaine assure une
épreuve en belgique donc voila vous
abonnés absents pour convalescence mais
viviani qui est tombé 1 sur la classique
à travers la flandre 1 1 disputé
mercredi dernier l'équipe delko qu'on
apercevait également tout à l'heure
l'équipe d'al koud avec un un coureur
que vous aimez bien vous en parlait
régulièrement notamment sur l'antenne de
la chaîne l'équipe lorsqu'il est aligné
sur une épreuve comme quoi j'ai
l'oreille attentive
c'est un coureur venus d'érythrée le ce
pays africains donc représenté avec
binyam guillermet qui est un jeune
talent que vous semblez bien connaître
jérémy ouais c'est vrai que souvent je
le mets favoris ça
à croire qu'il va très vite au sprint et
c'est pas faux enfants enfin les spas
est pas massif jl en gabarit donc ça
peut lui corresponde aujourd'hui pour
passer les bosses et oui j'ai découvert
sur le tour du gabon il avait remporté
une ou deux étapes est très jeune très
il y avait 19 ans a battu les courants
européen et couarde équipes françaises
et voilà ça m'a marqué j'ai vu qu'il
avait par la suite fait de très beau
très belle place donc c'est un cours que
je suis effectivement régulièrement
alors figurez-vous que moi aussi un
millième geremek à une de solides
caractéristiques sur le plan physique
instinct coureur très très très fort
physiquement un gros gros potentiel
physique pour ce garçon binyam guermai
qui assure des courses internationales
c'est aussi très bien comportée en ce
début de carrière
et pour l'instant c'est son coéquipier
alessandro fedeli kia continue d'ouvrir
la route sur un peloton qui prend toute
la route mais sans sens bataille et
maintenant c'est
l'échappée va reprendre pas mal de temps
là ce qu'on voit qu'ils sont de nouveau
bien organisée alors que le peloton est
totalement en roue libre
cette course voilà intéressant un
peloton qui s'est battu pour se placer
dans quant à proximité de ce moment
important
est-ce qu'il va continuer à se battre à
dans les prochains instants de course
et oui ça se concrétise par un écart qui
remonte insensiblement et l'échappée qui
a repris plus de 40 secondes à pour
atteindre quasiment 2 minutes vous aviez
vu juste avec ce peloton qui a nettement
réduit l'alluré où et ses notables un
ici avec un peloton qui fait presque
rideau entre guillemets qui redonne
quelque chose aux hommes de tête qui
vont pouvoir repasser au delà des 2
minutes à la proche des 50 derniers
kilomètres
alors certains ça reste un avantage
assez peu conséquents mais bien pourquoi
ne pas y croire c'est vrai que c'est pas
le tout en entretenir à 2 minutes mais
après faut les bouchers donc quand qu'on
entretient qu'on revient à une 30 une
vingtaine 10,1 vaut mieux maintenir à
une disque 2
que de revoir le chrono remontait à 2 30
voix surtout quand on va aborder ce
final plutôt plutôt dangereux en terme
de placement avec parmi les cinq hommes
de tête un certain alessandro fait des
liens qui pourraient profiter
là aussi bien de ses nombreuses courte
ascension pour essayer de sortir à la
le courant du team delko qui
s'était imposé sur la dernière étape du
tour du limousin à limoges
l'été dernier devant un ancien champion
du monde
rui costa le portugais 1 preuve de la
performance de ce coureur italien de 25
ans les cendres ont fait des lits qui a
un participe pour la première fois la
roue tourangelle et qui fait pour
l'instant à cause commune avec ses
partenaires d'échappée valentin fierons
le coureur de total direct energie dylan
kowalski est toujours présent en tête
pour la formation que ces listes roubaix
lille métropole
et puis il ya également le champion de
norvège espoirs martin uriane stades de
ligue 2 l'équipe u know it pro cycling
team et enfin le suisse s'était richir
de la formation suisse racing academy
voilà pour cette composition du groupe
des cinq une équipe la suisse racing qui
a monté en grade 1 depuis quelques mois
et qui participe désormais à de
nombreuses épreuves de la coupe de
france formation a drivé par l'ancien
amateurs sylvain blanquefort qui a été
régulièrement ces dernières années parmi
les meilleurs amateurs du cyclisme
français
une équipe dans laquelle on retrouve un
jeune coureur français à l'oif charrin
mais également l'écossais stuart belfort
qui a participé aux belles heures de
l'équipe côtes d'armor marie morin chez
les amateurs avant de passer
professionnel
voilà encore une une preuve du
ralentissement du peloton ici un qui
roule aller à 35 kilomètres heure
peut-être à cet endroit
agir est pas jusqu au pronostic de la
vitesse et pluton acquis maintenant à un
retard de deux minutes 15
oui et en l'espace de cinq kilomètres on
a perdu une minute du côté du peloton un
prof que le rythme a nettement baissé et
on retrouve notamment sur la droite de
la l'image plutôt sur la droite de la
chaussée
la remontée un des rouge et noir de
l'équipe arkéa samsic avec un acerbois
ni revanchard 1 va pas revenir dans les
détails sur ce qu'il s'est passé
dimanche dernier
mais on imagine un totalement revanchard
avec un un petit debriefing après la
course avec thomas boudât son poisson
pilote et qui elle avait envoyé du du
mauvais côté de la chaussée la semaine
dernière on imagine que cette formation
aura à coeur de se racheter
cet après midi
dylan kowalski qui s'est refait la
cerise comme on dit dans le jargon
cycliste qui passait qui passe son bout
de relais de nouveau on parle dans
l'oreillette du côté de la norvège et de
la formation il au x avec martine rioux
stade une équipe unique ce qui brille
également sur le circuit européen
et attention un jeune coureur qui est
l'un des talents du cyclisme mondial
dont on entendra parler très
probablement dans les semaines à venir
c'est son run varens gold avec à la
position de leader dans cette équipe de
sarsan 31 qui est un un jeune garçon
plein de talent et qu'il faudra
surveiller la progression cet après midi
à une voix qui nous parle qui en font
ici sur cette ligne d'arrivée celle de
daniel mangeas le speaker de l'épreuve
qui nous a rejoints après avoir présenté
les coureurs au départ tout à l'heure du
côté de sainte maure de touraine
alors que nous survolons magnifique
château d'azay-le-rideau actuellement
petite pub quand même pour les châteaux
locaux
alors tout cela c'était vos routes
d'entraînement vous rouliez de quel côté
du département lorsque vous étiez encore
coureur cycliste professionnel du rémy
s'était pas m'aimer routes les plus
fréquentées on va dire les routes qui
était au sud de la loire
moi j'étais plus sur le nord du
département limites avait cherché la
sarthe souvent on pourrait chercher des
bois c'est un peu plus long
en revanche sont celles de jonathan
hivert 1 lui qui est originaire et qui
réside du côté de cusset qui est situé
justement dans le au sud de tours un
tout près de sainte maure de touraine
justement c'est le village voisin de
sainte maure jonathan hivert qui qui est
un véritable profil pour lui un c'est un
coureur qui marche bien qu'ils sortent
de paris-nice et quand on voit la
lecture du profil des 40 derniers
kilomètres quand on connaît le profil
justement les caractéristiques de
jonathan hivert qui est un remarquable
puncheur on peut imaginer qu'il pourrait
essayer d'anticiper lé débat également
tout à l'heure oui ça qu'il a le profil
pour ça ces petites bosses et petit
coteau il est très punchy très explosif
il aura à coeur de briller sur ses
terres donc c'est vrai qu'on a eu on
peut s'attendre à ce qu'ils soient
offensifs et elle voir passer à l'action
dans ce final jonathan hivert qui fait
partie des courants les plus
expérimentés également en termes d'âge 1
c'est le deuxième coureur le plus âgé de
ce peloton
du haut de ses 36 ans l'a fêté ses 36
ans il ya moins de deux semaines
ce pourrait être un beau cadeau un pour
jonathan qui est remarquable palmarès 1
qui a gagné également au plus haut
niveau mondial notamment sur le tour de
romandie
mais également sur la course au soleil à
paris nice le vainqueur de l'étape de
châtel guyon seul fabio sabatini 1
l'italien de cofidis et plus âgés un pur
bien pour un mois seulement alors qu'il
y à un adverse de très jeunes coureurs
dans ce peloton l'équipe le taux cairns
aus l'équipe allemande que l'on connaît
un peu moins bien c'est présenté jérémy
avec deux coureurs de 18 ans espoir
première année sortant des juniors c'est
pour ces garçons là la première grande
épreuve dans leur carrière
r l'équipe de formation du cou qui
n'hésite pas à lancer des jeunes qui
doit qui doit avoir un calendrier
mélangeant des courses de classe une
comme comme la roue tourangelle des
courses de catégorie un peu plus
inférieur où il ya plus de jeunes
coureurs au départ 18 ans pour un claus
bentzinger et pour moritz à chaz a qui
sont les deux coureurs les plus jeunes
donc en termes d'âge sur cette épreuve
et puis le courant le plus expérimenté
en termes de participation dans le
peloton c'est tony hurel qui participe
pour la sixième fois à la roue
tourangelle
tony hurel qui lui aussi a connu la
redescente chez les amateurs pour mieux
rebondir en c1 choses assez fréquente
actuellement on voit beaucoup de
coureurs malheureusement donc
à quitter le monde professionnel pour
mieux y rentrer j'espère que ce sera le
même scénario pour un johan lebon par
exemple qui a retrouvé les rangs
amateurs également cette année donc
j'espère pour lui qu'il arrivera à
retrouver un contrat l'an prochain il a
prouvé qu'il avait encore le niveau il a
remporté récemment une épreuve élite
ainsi qu'une deuxième classe
hier c'est ça une course par étapes en
bretagne le tour du pays de lesneven
il est actuellement même sur le vélo on
peut l'imaginer johan lebon qui a été
votre coéquipier 1
par le passé on peut voir que c'est de
nouveau un petit peu nerveux en tête de
peloton
sortie dès et le rideau le vent un peu
plus favorable mais bon je pense je
pense que ce sera encore un petit peu
trop protégé pas assez à découvert pour
provoquer une sélection au moment où les
coureurs sont entrés officiellement dont
les 50 derniers kilomètres
peu après le passage du côté de
azay-le-rideau on s'en rapproche a
notamment à de ce kilomètre en or tout à
l'heure le kilomètre pavé à proximité de
villandry elle s'est peut-être à partir
de cet endroit là que le final sera
totalement lancé le ton qui ne se
découvre pas plus que cela pour le pour
le moment mais ça ne saurait tarder et
c'est vrai que sur la carte on pouvait
penser qu'il y avait
c'est une zone un peu plus dangereuse
mais voilà avec le coteau à côté c'était
c'était assez couvert assez à l'abri il
y aura un enchaînement tout à l'heure le
kilomètre pavé à villandry qui sera
rapidement suivie de kilomètres plus
tard par 7 à monter la montée de
villandry avec et bien un peu moins d'un
kilomètre d'ascension et cet
enchaînement pourrait faire basculer la
course éventuellement à l'entrée des 30
l'ultime kilomètre l'écart deux minutes
25 actuellement entre les cinq échappés
et le peloton cinq échappés qui a
finalement ce sont bien réorganiser un
malgré l' attaque tout à l'heure de
valentin ferron on aurait peut être
n'aurait pu lui dire valentin c'est bien
gentil ton attaque mais on ne collabore
plus et finalement un ce groupe à penser
autrement à penser intelligemment en se
reformant un indé cohésion oui toujours
des rôles et que chacun chacun donne
chacun participe à faire évoluer cette
échappée mais j'ai l'impression qu'il
manque un petit peu quand même de
dynamisme
même si le ton est pas lancer ce serait
bien qu'elle prenne un peu plus de
champs actuellement même si sur ce final
c'est pas évident forcément pour un
peloton de s'organiser avec toutes ces
routes sinueuses ses montées et ses
descentes ça peut revenir très vite mais
bon en l'occurrence les images et me
font mentir nouveau ralentissement
nouveau ralentissement dans le peloton
professionnel quand on ralentit l'alluré
ne fait pas mine un généralement après
un début de course 1 c'est le cas vous
en avez vécu de très nombreux des débuts
de course extrêmement intense avec
parfois une heure à 50 de moyenne et
ensuite des passages à 25 km heure ouais
t'as fait ça dépend vraiment de pas mal
de circonstance de
des équipes des stratégies des équipes
qui ont roule épuisé voilà des effets de
l'effet de course aussi comme la le
peloton c'était terreur on pourrait
organiser un petit peu pour se replacer
pour que les équipes se replacent devant
du coup le rythme était vraiment
augmenter passé le danger voilà l'équipe
qui ont roulé revient devant heroes
temporise
est ce qu'il est arrivé de vous ennuyer
dans un peloton pendant une course
jérémy ce que j'ai le droit de le dire
maintenant tout est possible mais oui ça
m'est arrivé plusieurs fois aura des
fois ça avec c'est un petit peu long
surtout qu'on espère prendre l'échappée
du départ et qui finalement là
n'arrivent pas à la prendre et puis
après il a toute une période où de
transition on traîne un peu ça me va là
où il se passe pas vrai parce qu'il se
passe pas grand chose et puis voilà faut
attendre que le leur entrée dans le
final un peu plus débridé pour retomber
retomber dans le match alors que la
caravane à nous rejoint pendant ce temps
là ici sur la ligne d'arrivée
oui un même en période de huis clos une
période plus difficile est bien une
course cycliste ça reste festif et
notamment dans l'esprit dans la tête des
organisateurs c'est une belle chose de
voir les partenaires de l'épreuve ainsi
salué avec la mise en place de cette
caravane qui était parti un cône sur le
tour de france près de deux heures avant
les coureurs
la voici à la l'issue de ce long cortège
204 km entre sainte maure de touraine et
tour il y en a beaucoup moins à vol
d'oiseau mais on est allé chercher
effectivement toutes les difficultés du
coin ici en touraine pour proposer le
parcours le plus compliqué possible aux
coureurs la coupe de france qui voit
beaucoup d'épreuves en se terminer au
sprint alors tout dépend évidemment des
caractéristiques de chaque course mais
on a régulièrement des scénarios qui a
ressemblé les uns aux autres et c'est
pour cela que les organisateurs essaient
de trouver quelques nouveautés chaque
année un salaire les hommes de tête sont
dansées
dans cette partie je dirais j'annonce
autant la partie finale où on va
commencer à attaquer cet enchaînement de
difficultés et convierait à lignières de
touraine mais on peut le voir un ce sont
des routes très étroites et c'est à dire
qu'il reste désormais un peu moins de 42
km de course
une heure et nous connaîtrons le
vainqueur nous connaîtrons le successeur
de lionel taminiaux au palmarès de la
roue tourangelle a qu'en sera-t-il
réponse donc sur les coups de 17 heures
15 un petit peu moins peut-être et
d'entrée les premiers coteaux que l'on
va voir apparaître puisque les coureurs
sont à quelques hectomètres de la loire
les cinq échappés donc roue dans roue
pour le moment à descendre au fait des
lits martin oriane stade valentin
fierons en troisième position dylan
kowalski le quatrième et théry schir le
cinquième qui ferme la marche
est-ce que valentin ferron ne serait pas
le lobe le plus frais dans cette
échappée c'est lui qui a porté l'attaqué
la plus violente tout à l'heure quel est
votre sentiment sur l'état de fatigue
des uns et des autres comme ça à l'oeil
oui j'en fait échapper un petit peu
poussier donc effectivement matin ferron
semble semble le plus armé alors qu'il
ya déjà une attaque en tête du peloton
c'est le genre d'âgés de zaire citroën
exactement du côté de lignières de
touraine alors est-ce qu'un coureur
comme nom de peters est passé à
l'attaqué à la proche des 40 derniers
kilomètres ce serait son style est oui
l'homme qui a gagné à antholz anterselva
le pays de biathlon il a imité un
certain martin fourcade mais c'était sur
le vélo et à l'occasion du tour d'italie
d'une équipe ag2r citroën acquis à se
présente aujourd'hui avec à des garçons
de talent ont un comme alexis gougeard
évidemment julien duval qui est déjà
monté sur le podium de cette épreuve ou
encore anthony julien qui est un jeune
coureur qui est un vrai puncheur
également en plus des hommes rapides que
son d'orient godon marc sarreau et
clément venturini
en tout cas le coureur ag2r citroën a
pris la petite centaine de mètres en
avant sur le peloton mais les seules n'a
pas été suivi un parent à un coureur
d'une autre formation une chute dans ce
virage milieu du peloton à la corde
ça s'anime 1
il me semblait aussi un stand pieters
vue d'hélicoptère à bientôt la
confirmation
ouais c'est lui 1 je vais pas me
prononcer à 100% encore attendre un
petit peu mais c'était le style un vide
et les when the meters pour moi
on va attendre la confirmation là aussi
du côté de l'équipe ag2r citroën team
lance peters vainqueur d'étape sur le
tour d'italie mais pas seulement
puisqu'il fait partie des vainqueurs
français sur le dernier tour de france
après au terme d'un numéro remarquable
sur les routes de laruns dans les
pyrénées
il avait battu un certain humour
saccharine dans la descente
la descente finale après avoir
parfaitement négocié notamment le port
de balès et peyresourde et peyresourde
effectivement pour rejoindre la localité
de loudenvielle je disais à laruns tout
à l'heure la reims était le lendemain
avec un la victoire slovène de tabac et
boogat tort alors qu'en est-il de
l'écart un véritable accélération en
tête de peloton maintenant alors qu'on
est entré dans les 40 derniers
kilomètres et ça se confirme a nnonce
peters a bel et bien attaquer et un
peloton qui en profite pour reprendre
très vite du champ on sent un il ya
beaucoup de fatigue en tête et les
écarts à descendre aussi vite qu'ils
sont montés puisque l'écart est passé à
une minute 15 seulement entre la tête de
la course et et le peloton
hanspeter s'intercaler à une minute
oui ça revient vite on le sentait cette
échappée qui continuait de vent mais qui
n'avait pu vraiment avoir de dynamique
de relance et de maintenir un rythme
très élevé c'est pour ça aussi que ce
peloton a temporisé à plusieurs reprises
hun sen t bien que l'échappée était
était sous contrôle
dans le moteur ce qui est un coureur qui
ne gagnent pas très souvent mais quand
ils gagnent ne fait pas les choses à
moitié c'est leur professionnel de
numéro et sur deux des plus grandes
courses mondiales une étape sur le tour
d'italie en montagne devant esteban
chaves qu'il avait lâché à la ce
jour là dans la montée finale d'antholz
anterselva et puis à bis repetita
l'année suivante à l'été dernier sur le
tour de france au mois de septembre à la
sortie de l'été sur la première étape
pyrénéenne en solitaire là aussi
dans un style caractéristique que l'on
reconnaît assez facilement en hand
peters qui se déhanche un petit peu leur
pas autant que son ancien coéquipier
pierre latour mais ça bouge des épaules
chez nantes ce qui est très efficace sur
le vélo lorsqu'il est lancé
un coureur qui se décrit comme un déjà
un petit diesel lorsqu'il attaque de
loin dans une échappée au long cours
n'est jamais aussi fort que dans la
dernière heure / qu'il a déjà prouvé son
efficacité dans la dernière heure ça
c'est indéniable sur ces deux belles
victoires à chaque fois résistance ici
sur un profil qui lui est un peu moins
adapté un même si ça va monter
régulièrement en fin de parcours c'est
plutôt un adepte des courses en haute
montagne avec des cols beaucoup plus
long oui la problématique là c'est que
dans le peloton les coureurs qui ne
roulent pas qu'il ne le chassent pas
vont pouvoir ré accéléré dans la bosse
qui suit tandis que lui il est déjà un
effort presque maximal avec un vent un
petit peu défavorable sur cette portion
il va attaquer la prochaine boss il
pourra pas accélérer lui par contre oui
mais ça revient vite puisque les écarts
à viennent de nous être communiqué et
non de peters revient 30 secondes de la
tête de la course le peloton est à 45
secondes jérémy en l'espace de deux ou
trois kilomètres
on peut donc imaginer que très vite on
pourra assister un regroupement général
d'ea une toute nouvelle épreuve à
l'entâme des 35 derniers kilomètres
oui en l'occurrence là sûrement voir un
anti peeters qui va revenir sur
l'échappée qui va peut-être est déposée
au passage mais le peloton c'est vrai
que arrive à rester menaçant
l'inspecteur ne n'arrive pas forcément à
creuser suffisamment pour l'instant et
c'est normal et qui peut groupama fdj
actuellement en tête ne souhaite pas non
plus le voir prendre trop de champ ils
le connaissent il connaît son potentiel
alors là tous les sprinteurs rentrer
dans la fameuse heure critique avant
l'arrivée de la roue tourangelle qui est
une course que l'on promet généralement
aux sprinteurs mais il ya une heure
critique à venir avec ce dénivelé dans
les 40 derniers kilomètres il faudra
tenir quand on exprime toi voilà
exactement exactement c'est ça c'est cet
enchaînement de 17 dernières difficultés
ces petites routes puis c'est ses
incessantes attaques qui risque de se
produire la première séance peeters
qu'il l'a mise en verra si on a d'autres
aussi
ou s'ils vont laisser danse pieters tout
seul s'épuiser devant ou s'il y aura
d'autres équipes qui m'ont tenter de
dynamiser tout ça est de provoquer un
peu plus de fatigue pour ses équipes de
sprinteurs
les images aériennes qui a sont proposés
depuis l'hélicoptère et qui nous
permettent justement est bien de
visualiser l'écart entre la tête de
course et le contre attaquant et on voit
très bien que ça se resserre il n'ya
plus que 300 400 mètres d'écart entre
les deux premières par de la course est
derrière le collectif groupama fdj et
qui se met en place ça me fait penser
aux derniers championnats de france où
l'est l'équipe groupama vidéo j avais
réussi à contrôler toute la course
pendant à près de 250 km pour faire
gagner arleux des moeurs c'était une
performance collective assez
impressionnante déjà benjamin thomas qui
roule donc et d'avoir pas mal d'équipier
conduit est distancé les premiers les
premiers coureurs l'équipe obama et vj
qu'on voulait on peut compter sur
benjamin thomas pour faire le travail
d'un ou des hommes oui a pu semer en
plus mais c'est vrai que formidable
rouleur champion de france
contre-la-montre et spécialistes sur
piste de la poursuite et de l'omnium qui
roulait très vite et aussi très
longtemps
le mans contre qui n'est plus qu'à 20
secondes désormais est de la tête de
course alors que les hommes de tête
un rôle pour l'instant une moyenne
n'approche des 41 km heure depuis le
départ de l'épreuve
il se rapproche de villandry un peu un
peu avec ce fameux secteurs pavés long
de 800 mètres
c'est l'une des attractions du parcours
jérémy roy depuis la dernière édition en
oui les coureurs là n'auront plus de
difficultés jusqu'à ce secteur pavé la
seule difficulté qui aura ce sera un
virage à l'épinglé un petit kilomètre
avant vous voulez corps on est quasiment
à l'arrêt mais bon il n'y aura pas trop
de soucis
puis ouais ce kilomètre en or qui est
baptisé la part la roue tourangelle
ce passage pavé ça servira en fait de
rampe de lancement pour la côte de
villandry elle restera cet endroit à 33
km exactement le grand final nous y
entrons nous y sommes la roue
tourangelle va bientôt livrer son
verdict avec toujours 5 échappés 1 dans
le spectateur ce n'est pour l'instant
pas revenu il est à moins de 15 secondes
le grimpeur isérois
que les parents prennent omenex en
hommage à la série d'époque nonce
l'héberger vainqueur d'étape donc nous
le disions sur le tour d'italie le tour
de france et ça se resserre un parce que
derrière nantes peters 15 secondes plus
loin il y a aussi le peloton
l'ensemble des coureurs de cette roue
tourangelle se tiennent maintenant dans
un mouchoir de poche et des routes un
peu plus étroites maintenant en route un
peu plus sinueuse avec toujours un seul
groupe de tête kowalski qui ferme la
marche
dylan kowalski sort d'un très bon début
de saison alessandro fedeli juste
derrière lui l'italien de la formation
delko l'italien qui a dispose lui des
des plus belles références dans ce
groupe d'échappés
alors que aux côtés de benjamin thomas
il ya le jeune britannique un lewis à
ski qui est toujours représentée en tête
de peloton on a eu un gros travail en
début d'épreuve de paul penhoët qui
s'est ensuite écarté
échappée qui arrive à résister jusqu'à
présent anti peeters devrait plus tarder
à revenir et c'est pamela qui arrive
bientôt
allez quoi vont remonter faire ce virage
à l'épinglé sur la droite prochainement
un souvenir de pavés jérémy dans votre
carrière
c'était pas votre votre non pas trop
c'était pas ma tasse de thé
même si j'ai fait pareil roubaix pour ma
première année pro au pied levé en
remplacement de dernière minute
j'avais terminé mais voilà j'en étais
resté là mais autre expérience c'était
près sur des étapes du tour de france
les quelques pavés donc lui son maître
de secteur pavé la 107e rang ce virage à
bord le demi tour voilà oui là dans un
petit kilomètre maintenant les coureurs
on arrivait à pleine vitesse sion s'est
pas vu la faveur de ce virage on
contempler les écarts qui continue de se
resserrer nonce peters est en chasse
patate au milieu a donc de cette
situation de course
et voilà pourquoi aussi ce passage pavé
rendues difficiles si vous avez pu voir
ces virages à l'épinglé cours ne peuvent
pas tout se passe est lancée et il y en
a qui ont dû mettre pied à terre tout
simplement derrière fallait être bien
placé ça y est le voici nantes peters
qui a fait officiellement la jonction
sur une route très étroite un ici du
côté un des bords du cher
il a fait la jonction le sont donc s'ils
sont est désormais trois cours en
français non speter ce pour ag2r citroën
dylan kowalski pour l'information que
ces listes roubaix lille métropole
il y a également valentin ferron 1 pour
le team total direct energie
martin uriane stada représente la
norvège et les couleurs de hugo x pro
cycling team à descendre au fait des
l'italien du team delko et enfin le
suisse s'était richir poursuit ce racing
academy et on aperçoit au loin
effectivement le secteur pavé et le
peloton qui revient très très fort ils
ont profité de la relance pour accélérer
on peut le voir que presque des cassures
déjà dans ce peloton le ton en file
indienne
et pour ceux qui se posaient la question
non le scénario 2019 ne se répétera pas
le peloton va manger tout cru les hommes
de tête dans les instants à venir et
pourquoi pas sur ce secteur pavé on sait
jamais évident de reprendre des
échappées sur un secteur pavé
ça va créer un petit peu la zizanie et
le belle attaque de noces peters qu'a
bien compris que ses compagnons de fugue
sont beaucoup plus fatigués beaucoup
moins de force évidemment 1 et surtout
que le peloton revient très fort
elle ne pouvait plus se permettre de
récupérer malheureusement pour lui il
fallait déjà repasser à l'offensive et
il n'a pas pu attendre la prochaine boss
les ventes y entrer un sûr à ce secteur
d'un instant à l'autre maintenant il
restera 33 km c'est une route très
sympathique pour la balade du dimanche
après midi
mais en ce qui concerne à la roue
tourangelle et son final c'est plus
usant bayer les voici
et ça commence par un faux plat
descendant histoire de d'augmenter
encore la vitesse de ce peloton avec un
petit peu de poussière sur le côté
gauche de ce secteur où la surface
semble un peu plus roulante aussi un les
courants ont choisi le côté gauche pour
éviter au maximum les vibrations n'est
pas très long un petit kilomètre un
virage à gauche et c'est ici que ça va
se durcir forcément à la relance
attention à ne pas glisser
les coureurs ont pris quelques
précautions les abus beaucoup freiné
réduire leur allure à l'approché du
virage avec peters qui est suivi par le
suisse théry schir valentin ferron en
troisième position
et voilà on est déjà ressorti avec des
images du peloton maintenant peut-être
pour savoir comment se déroule la
traversée de ce secteur pavé sera
intéressant de voir s'il ya des cassures
dans le peloton effectivement mais la
deuxième moto caméra on peut l'imaginer
ne peut pas se glisser entre les deux
groupes parce que le peloton revient
très près et ne sont plus que quatre en
tête maintenant jérémy ray sous la halle
attaques suite à l'attaqué d'un
inspecteur effectivement c'est terminé
pour kowalski et s'est terminé également
pour alessandro fedeli qui n'ont pas
réussi à tenir le rythme il n'y a plus
que peters accompagné de uriane stade le
norvégien
le suisse à chi est également aux avant
postes ainsi que valentin ferron pour la
formation total direct energie le
peloton semble avoir passé le secteur
sans encombre on peut le voir en
arrière-plan que nous voyons le fameux
château et les jardins de villandry
alors ça va s'enchaîner directement avec
la montée qui porte le même nom
voilà on va passer le long du château
est grimpé à côte au coteau de villandry
est peut-être un le terrain d'expression
pour de nouvelles attaques en tête de
peloton avec des formations qui ont tout
intérêt à essayer de dynamiter ce groupe
principal les équipes qui ne présente
pas de sprinter rapide en son sein et
bien seront peut-être aux avant-postes
dans les instants à venir
nans peters qui anime en tout cas ce
final à 30 kilomètres de l'arrivée
il a rejoint une partie de l'échappée il
donne son rôle est maintenant à l'autre
français valentin environ le coureur
poitevin est de cette équipe total
direct energie est très belle prestation
valentin ferron jeune coureur course qui
doit lui tenir à coeur aussi à lui le
voisin de poitiers et les coureurs qui
vont continuer à longer le fleuve royal
ainsi jusqu'à tours avec quelques
crochets par les coteaux et décrocher il
y en aura 1 puisque suite à la cote de
villandry il y aura ensuite notamment la
côte rude et carnot celle de l'epan
également qui interviendra a donc à
proximité de tours
vous pouvez choisir le halage la
chaussée c'est comme vous voulez aller
premier crochet c'est parti justement
avec le virage sur la droite a tout de
suite enchaîné à un juste après le
château par la montée de belles images 1
à proposer
grâce à cette vue aérienne on parle
beaucoup de châteaux de point de vue ici
dans la région la belle région de
touraine les vignobles
évidemment le fromage également c'était
le sujet un tout à l'heure du côté de
sainte maure de touraine
réputé pour son fromage de chèvre
il n'ya plus que 150 mètres d'écart 1
tout au plus entre l'échappée et le
peloton à des coureurs sont dans
l'ascension la voir si dans le peloton
ça s'active aussi pour relancer pour
durcir encore plus même si le tempo est
déjà très élevé 1 comme on peut se
l'imaginer
alors qu'on annonce jérémy un peu
ignatas konovalovas ça a été distancé
par le peloton
un homme de base 1 pour arnaud démare
qui peut-être a subi tout à l'heure le
secteur pavé nom de peters qui tentent
de sortir du lot encore une fois dans ce
groupe de tête
beaucoup plus frais que ses adversaires
et les attaques derrière des habitants
terrifiés encore ag2r citroën qui
relance derrière alors est-ce peut-être
un coureur comme dorian godon tout à
l'heure ries attention là et commence à
avoir pas mal de coureurs qui sortent la
course d'anticipation qui débute il y a
certes les sprinteurs qui attendent leur
heure dans les derniers kilomètres mais
avant cela et bien ces coteaux pourrait
profiter aux puncheurs
ça semble bien parti oui belles belles
tentatives là avec des écarts à des
micros et car pour le moment puisqu'il
n'ya qu'une cinquantaine de mètres
d'avancé sur le peloton
une dizaine d'hommes ont réussi à
prendre quelques longueurs d'avancé mais
là faut boucher tout de suite hein sinon
ça risque d'être compliqué max peeters
va se sacrifier ses goûts dont 1 je
crois qu est dans sa roue
accor de cofidis qui aussi la couarde
arquilla nouveaux coureurs de total
direct energie
et on bascule donc au sommet de cette
côte de villandry pour relancer le
rythme dans la descente maintenant alors
qu'une partie de cette échappée vient de
se faire rattraper par le peloton
pierre luc périchon qu'on aperçoit ici
en première position il prend son relais
pour l'équipe cofidis
l'ancien vainqueur de paris camembert
entre autres qui avaient réussi à une
excellente performance sur un
championnat d'europe sous les couleurs
de l'équipe de france à glasgow
ap richmond il a un profil de course 1
qui peut être tout à fait adapté
également ses caractéristiques
oui solide rouleur offensif passe bien
les bosses c'est vrai que toutes les
caractéristiques requises pour provoquer
un beau final et faire évoluer cette
échappée escaut jarque est devant oui il
me semble serait peut-être plus que
jarque kogo non effectivement mais
alexis gougeard effectivement qui est en
première position ici le solide un
rouleur de la formation ag2r citroën un
double vainqueur de la classic loire
atlantique entre autres dans ces
carrières
elles sont maintenant 7,7 à ouvrir la
route
et on chante on s'entend très bien pour
le moment 1 suite à cet excellent
accélération dans la côte de villandry
l'enchaînement va être rapide 1 derrière
puisqu'il y aura dans les 30 derniers
kilomètres d'autres montent et toutes ne
sont pas répertoriés la côte de la
montée jaune
la cote de bois renaud également qui
seront les prochaines gravi par les
coureurs de la roue tourangelle a du mal
à s'entendre devant ça repart à deux
avec perrichon avec peeters des coûts
jarki aussi fait la jonction
c'est pas évident alors entre les
coureurs qu'on fait un petit bout
d'échapper au long cours enfin allons
vous échapper et ces nouveaux coureurs
qui sont venus prêter main-forte qui
viennent de sortir du peloton
oui certes certains essais et fonde la
survie dans cette course il s'accroche
pendant que d'autres temps de prendre du
champ sur le peloton mais on a surtout
ici des hommes feraient un qui semble
parvenir à se détacher
en tout cas on a une belle présence de
l'équipe ag2r citroën puisque on a vu un
tour à tour des coureurs comme à nantes
ce peters comme alexis gougeard d'orient
godon également tout à l'heure on
s'oriente peut-être vers une jonction
dans cette descente puisque le peloton 1
à bigard a quelques secondes seulement
alors l'opération un critique a débuté
pour les sprinteurs qui sont pour
l'instant à caler dans les roues mais on
n'a vu qu'une qu'une partie évidemment
de ses montées qui vont s'enchaîner
avoir trouvé une petite portion un peu
plus plane la banda de rechercher de
nouveaux coteaux tout petit peu de répit
mais ça ne va pas durer très longtemps
allaient ils sont cinq ou six à prendre
le large ou plutôt un peu plus parce
qu'il y à deux éléments également juste
devant eux ne sont pas faire prendre
dans la descente avec ce virage
technique en bas ils ont réussi à
conserver quelques mètres sept coureurs
en tête donc un pierre luc périchon ici
en première position pour la formation
cofidis
les coureurs à la sortie de la localité
de savonnières et dans un kilomètres la
pente va se dresser de nouveau sous les
roues un des coureurs de la roue
tourangelle qui la montée jaune suivi
immédiatement de la côte du bois renaud
puis après on aura le droit à
l'enchaînement des carnot et de l'epan
courant du team des locaux qui donnent
son relais à la formation ag2r citroën
difficile pour l'instant de reconnaître
tous les coureurs puisque nous ne sommes
pas juste à côté d'eux des éléments
toujours est il que le peloton contrôler
un peloton qui ne musarde plus
maintenant à l'arrière du peloton le
voit on est en file indienne à partir de
la 50e 60e position
et ouais on est obligé de faire beaucoup
de sacrifices en reste quand même encore
25 km mais faut pas la laisser partir
cette échappée alors là ça peut nuire
évidemment outre un des sprinteurs qui
vont lâcher quelques coéquipiers en
route
voilà tout à fait je fais beaucoup de
force perdu dans la bataille quand on a
envie d'avoir un train ou des poissons
pilotes pour les sprinteurs mais ça fait
partie du jeu et des équipes qui ne sont
pas là pour le sprint et ils ont bien
raison d'en profiter d' attaquer
il n'y a que cinq petites secondes
d'écart et tout pourrait se réunir donc
du côté de la prochaine montée les
coureurs sont au pied
les nouvelles attaques nouvelle
accélération dans de la part de la tête
de la course perd ce ne sont jamais des
ascensions longue mais très punchy
effectivement très nerveuse qui 1
profite au meilleur rapport
poids/puissance au vrai puncheur
en tête donc alexis gougeard à mais
également clément venturini
effectivement qu était l'homme qui
venait de porter cette célébration est
que venturini qui se découvre on a donc
une un élément de réponse sur la
tactique d'âge et 2h citroën ou le
sprinteur un numéro un sera très
probablement marc sarreau venturini
gougeard accompagner un par pierre luc
périchon de cofidis auguste jensen le
norvégien du team delko simonet velasco
également attention à cet homme pour la
formation gazprom russe vélo simonet
velasco le coureur italien et puis robin
froidevaux représentant les couleurs
rouge et noire de la suisse racing
academy voilà pour la composition du
groupe de tête
belle relance la de clément venturini 1
qui a permis à l'échappée de reprendre
du champ
un venturini donc qui a exposé qui
anticipent peut-être qu'il va surtout
pousser les formations concurrentes à se
livrer en tête de peloton
un groupe a même des gis sera t elle
suffisamment solides cet après midi
c'est la question évidemment sinon on
peut se poser la question est ce qu'il y
aura des renforts d'autres équipes
c'est pas dit attention à ceux ci
monnaies velasco maillot plan de la
gazprom russe vélo qui sort de tirreno
adriatico avec une troisième place sur
l'avant dernière étape
une route et une chose c'est beaucoup
plus large maintenant qui va cette
fois-ci profiter au peloton
même si même si jérémy à l'écart
augmenté 1 en faveur des échappées
maintenant oui l'écart augmenté mais on
va retrouver cette portion ce type de
route à plusieurs reprises puisqu'on va
monter descendre les coteaux et chaque
fois on retombe sur cette route là ont
l'art quitte pour pour la deuxième côte
la coupe du bois renaud
on la retrouvera tout à l'heure cette
cette belle route ou effectivement le
peloton pourra mieux sera organisé pour
aller chercher le final avec
l'enchaînement des carnot et de l'epan
avec clément venturini qu'on aperçoit
ici sur la droite de l'image le champion
de france de cyclo cross
l'ancien vainqueur des quatre jours de
dunkerque à clément venturini qui se
construit peu à peu est également un
très beau palmarès sur la route
la cote de bois renault a été l'une des
toutes dernières montées du jour c'est
l'antépénultième montée de cette roue
tourangelle qui comptait au départ 28
ascension et bien voici la 26e
marlon gaillard qu'on annonce également
aux avant-postes un marlon ghayoor et
c'est intéressant en puisque c'est
l'autre local de l'étape on parlait tout
à l'heure de jonathan hivert
le tourangeau marlon gaillard qui a à
coeur évidemment de briller sur ses
terres sur des routes qu'il connaît bien
l'homme de chine on ne savait pas très
bien ce qu'il attendait au départ de
l'épreuve
aura-t-il à la carte de coureur protégé
ou alors entre rats at-il de plain pied
dans son rôle d'équipier pour niccolo
bonifacio et bien il semblerait qu'on
ait donné carte blanche
carte blanche à au jeune coureur
tourangeau
c'est bien pour lui qu'il ait pu saisir
comme ça son opportunité de suivre les
bonnes échappées avec ce groupe qui se
dessine maintenant à l'avant sous
l'impulsion de clément venturini
pour luc périchon on rappelle donc la
composition un jérémy avec à pierre luc
périchon pour la formation cofidis ils
ne sont plus que six à désormais il est
accompagné par auguste jansens du team
delko gougeard et venturini représente
la formation donc la plus étoffée aux
avant-postes ag2r citroën team
il y à l'italien velasco pour la gazprom
russe vélo et marlon gaillard de total
direct energie le suisse romain
froidevaux a été distancé par ce groupe
de tête dans la montée de la côte boire
nos petits moments d'accalmie la cette
descente de nouveau cette portion plane
en bas avant d'attaquer les deux
dernières difficultés
c'est très irrégulier ce final assez dur
de s'organiser derrière dans ces
conditions une mini classique ardennaise
avec des changements de direction est
très fréquent dans le limbourg
tourangeaux à la touraine est loin
d'être plate ça ne monte pas très haut
mais on ya quelques secteurs très
intéressant quand on est à vélo avec la
traversée de cette forêt
les coureurs vont se rapprocher de
ballan-miré il reste moins de 20
kilomètres nous y sommes maintenant dans
les 20 derniers kilomètres de cette
course toujours six coureurs devant
après que robin froid d'euros de suisse
racing académies étaient distancés
le ton n'est pas très loin la présence
de laurent pichon devant qui du coup
l'équipe
arqués à samsic ne roulera pas une fois
confiance alors pichon gaillard
puisqu'on a annoncé tout à l'heure
marlon d'ailleurs on a hâte de retrouver
les images pour et bien évidemment bien
différencier les tuniques mais cet écart
a augmenté tout à l'heure on annonce un
peloton pas très loin à ce peloton est
tout de même à une vingtaine de secondes
au moment où nous parlons et c'est le
collectif groupama fdj car plus les
rênes de ce peloton c'est vrai qu'au
niveau information suis à ce qu'on nous
donne récemment là on va attendre la
confirmation parce que là ce sont des
tuniques qu'on pourra assez facilement
identifiés pouvoir avoir une vision avec
la moto sur une portion plus plus
propice c'est vrai que c'est un terrain
accidenté qui est ne rend pas les choses
faciles aux motos caméra bien sûr et
c'est plus aérienne un du peloton ici en
tout cas le collectif et ag2r citroën
aura parfaitement dynamiser cette course
avec tout à leur nom speter dans un
premier temps qui a servait d'éclaireur
oui on a
effectivement en première position
un coureur de l'équipe arcas m6 qui a
donné son relais le cofidis est
également la ccar luc périchon et du
côté de l'équipe arkéa samsic donc la
présence de laurent pichon
le coureur originaire de quimper le
breton on aperçoit yens scène ici qui
donne le relais maintenant à alexis
gougeard et donc excusez-nous à mme
marland gaillard est annoncé par erreur
alors l'équipe obama fdj qui roule
toujours mais qui se trouve un petit peu
démunis eh oui si bien que c'est
maintenant l'équipe totale directe
énergique et l'autre formation piégé
finalement parce qu'on a devant un
coureur de cofidis pierre luc périchon
un homme de delko ses augustes jensen
deux représentantes ag2r citroën avec
gougeard et venturini un coureur de
gazprom russe vélo simonet velasco est
un homme de duty marqué à samsic laurent
pichon a pas de représentant pour le
team total direct energie etc et des
jeux de l'ontario
le ton y est on voit les images
affectivement ralenti ici c'est tomber
aux alentours de la 30e position
voilà une route beaucoup plus plane un
peu plus large non d'accalmie qui nous
permet de vous confirmer tout cela
venturini sur la droite derrière lui il
y a le dossard à 115,2 simonet velasco
qui semble ne pas prendre de relais 1
velasco qui sautent quelques relais
et on a une belle représentation du
contingent français avec à quatre
coureurs français désormais dans cette
échappée perrichon gougeard venturini et
pichon un italien avait lascaux et le
norvégien jens n il reste plus que 2
monte désormais la 27e et la 28e et
voilà on est déjà dans la prochaine
elle est raide attention parce qu'il ya
des passages à 12 % à certains endroits
et notamment au pied de cette montée
c'est là l'endroit le plus difficile
velasco attend son heure en sixième
position lui qui semble à garder un
maximum de forces pour tout à l'heure
oui il semble bien géré son affaire pour
l'instant est-ce que j'ai désert citroën
fait peur à tout le monde avec une
nouvelle attaque de clément venturini
maintenant venturini qui est
probablement le plus rapide des six
ouais voiture unis qui relance à nouveau
elle lui a tout intérêt évidemment à ce
que ça aille au bout de cette manière je
suis là une très très bonne pointe de
vitesse laurent plus laurent pichon qui
a parfaitement pris sa roue il revient
dans un excellent état de forme à
laurent pichon qui avait brillé sur la
coupe de france il ya quatre ans de cela
lorsqu'il avait gagné la route adélie de
vitré ainsi que la classic loire
atlantique
lui qui sort du tour de catalogne c'est
un profil qui ressemble à ce qu'il a
connu sur les routes espagnoles
laurent pichon ou le peloton qui est
déjà la grosse montée du peloton elle
sans attaque pour pour autant mais
effectivement un tempo extrêmement
intense du côté de la route des quarts
dos
et les coureurs sont maintenant entrés
dans les 15 derniers kilomètres à
l'hypothèse du sprint massif se précise
de plus en plus un il restera à la
montée de l'epan à suivre l aps le ton
est extrêmement allongée là ça peut
craquer à tout moment elle à avoir des
petites cassures et alors est ce les
groupements fdj on peut pas voir qui est
qui qui mène ce peloton
on a passé donc le sommet de l'avant
dernière montée du jour et arnaud d en
haut des marques a même pris les choses
en main en personne il a tenté fallait
revenir tout de suite ici le rendent pas
tout de suite c'est compliqué oui parce
qu'arnaud des morts en sa compagnie n'a
probablement plus que sa pulsion pilote
ça me fait contrer et attention là c'est
peut-être un moment important de la
course
elle était revenue très très près mais
pas suffisamment pour entrer arnaud
démare complètement esseulé désormais
pour le collectif groupama fdj cas était
à contrer par un coureur sur la droite
de la chaussée ne reste plus que la côte
de l'epan dont le pied va intervenir
dans deux kilomètres avec une attaque
d'un coureur de l'équipe a requis à
samsic de nouveaux puits nbi hôtel qui
roule aussi derrière forcément ils sont
piégés aussi peut-être jonathan hivert
qui tentent de sortir démarre en
deuxième position avec son maillot de
champion de france
ouais mais là il va être aux
avant-postes et ils vont compter dessus
va être compliqué un pouvoir ne démarre
aujourd'hui malheureusement j'ai
l'impression à moi qu'il arrive à
ressortir dans la côte de l'epan profite
aux hommes de tête toujours au nombre de
six voix la temporisation c'est fini à
les sprinteurs sont peut-être en train
de dire adieu au succès avec une
nouvelle attaque maintenant sur la
gauche de la route
si oui s'il n'y a pas de soutien des
équipes piégées à rouler plutôt que
d'attaquer la messe est dite comme on
dit un peloton qui a perdu beaucoup
beaucoup d'unités et la proche des dix
derniers kilomètres dans cette édition
en numéro 19 de la roue tourangelle
troisième manche de la coupe de france
qui va succéder à lionel tamini au
palmarès
en tout cas c'est un beau final c'est la
course 1 conforme à nos attentes
finalement à ce que nous attendions ce
matin oui totalement indécise dans ce
final tout était possible et là on peut
voir qu'il va manquer de d'équipier pour
pour arnaud démare s'est désorganisée en
tête de peloton l'échappée va prendre un
peu plus de champ mais arnaud démare
nacer bouhanni ans également qui fait
partie des coureurs piégés en tête de
peloton et qui a un équipier de vent
allait peut-être que nous allons
retrouver des images de la tête de
course et du poursuivant éventuellement
parce qu'il y ait un coureur qui était
sorti en contre attaque et il semblerait
qu'il ait fait la jonction
parce qu'ils sont maintenant 7 est un
deuxième coureur de l'équipe arkéa
samsic un qui devrait apparaître
maintenant sur les devants de la scène
on l'a vu sortir tout à l'heure sur la
droite de la chaussée
c'est lui qui avait construit en
personne arnaud des moeurs allez on
attaque les paons la ciar nos démarre
peut attaquer pour faire la jonction
ce serait l'idéal pour lui ou si
l'équipe total direct energie oublier
une bio tel est aussi c'est aussi les
équipes piégées
alors deux ag2r citroën et 2 arqués à
samsic en tête un cofidis et perd son
bichon attaques de laurent pichon le
coureur breton de l'équipe arcas annecy
qui a durci le rythme désormais à ces
boudins me semble-t-il qui est revenu
ensuite dans un second temps on va avoir
la confirmation de cette information
oui il me semble aussi que ses bouddhas
et attention il ya un ag2r du genre tu
es gougeard qui vient de se garer sur la
gauche de la chaussée dans les passages
à plus de 10% et pichon qui roulent le
plus fort évidemment parce qu'il le sait
son 2e sprinter thomas boudât et en sa
compagnie on pourrait s'orienter vers un
duel venturini bouddha ouais on
s'oriente vers un final comme ça
effectivement un duel venturini bouddha
alors dans le peloton où on en est ce
qui a eu des relances des attaques léman
venturini qui avait déjà terminé
deuxième de l'édition 2015
thomas boudât quant à lui et est
également moins n'est jamais monté sur
le podium il avait pris la 4e place il y
a deux ans en 2019
mais attention à simonet velasco 1 qui a
lui aussi une belle pointe de vitesse
oui qui est assez discret d'ailleurs
fait une raison et qui laisse faire les
chiens oui ils laissent faire les
équipes françaises 1 depuis une dizaine
de kilomètres simonet vela secours
et puis forcément la présence de deux
équipiers ne va pas favoriser les relais
1-2 perrichon et de velasco ce serait
logique qu'un de laisser toute la part
du travail à l'équipe ag2r citroën et à
l'équipe arkéa samsic velasco qui a
gagné dans sa carrière le trophée
lewyllie ya notamment qui s'est imposé
sur une étape de la semaine coppi
bartali et qui sort de tirreno adriatico
il n'y a pas de mystère les coureurs qui
sont parvenus à enchaîner ces dernières
semaines des épreuves difficiles au plus
haut niveau mondial sont en tête
alors qu'en est il du peloton maintenant
c'est évidemment ce qui nous intéresse
est ce que s'était échappée va pas
parvenir à prendre le meilleur
on rappelle qu alexis gougeard tout à
l'heure était sur le point d'être
décrochée il est revenu avec s'est fait
violence alexis qui accourent harkis et
atar qu'elle est juste derrière laurent
pichon en tête
venturini à la deuxième place le ton qui
n'est pas encore tout à fait battu angus
jensen était 3e ici sur l'image on a
passé donc la toute dernière montée la
côte de l'epan il reste de moins de dix
kilomètres avant l'arrivée
un venturini lui aussi un sort du tour
de catalogne qu'il a terminée il ya une
semaine seulement
il tourne autour 1 depuis le début de la
saison venturini avec une quatrième
place d'étape sur le tour la provence
une sixième place également sur une
étape 1
en catalogne l'étape gagnée par peter
sagan et son nouveau titre de champion
de france de cyclo cross une nouvelle
fois acquis cette année six coureurs
pour la gagne et ouais velasco tu n'es
plus de vent ainsi monnaies velasco a
été à distance et tout à l'heure il n'y
a plus que les équipes françaises
jérémy était distancé la défense j'ai
l'impression et c'est dorian godon qui
semble-t-il est parti en contre attaque
tout à l'heure l'homme intercalé en tête
pierre luc périchon pour l'équipe
cofidis deux coureurs de l'équipe arcas
hamsik thomas boudât et laurent pichon
de couronnes ag2r citroën alexis
gougeard et clément venturini et un
coureur pour l'équipe delko augusti
jensen et ces six là à tourner ils se
relaient mais attention pas le droit à
l'erreur pas l'aura la séquence
d'observation parce que les écarts sont
serrés
le peloton n'est qu'à 15 secondes hauts
d'asnières écart
venturini bouddha abouda venturini tu là
c'est une grande ligne droite un le
peloton d'avoir l'échappée en ligne de
mire portion un peu en vent de face en
plus distant sont sont plus courtes
alors est-ce qu'on a un dernier quart où
une vie sur le peloton savoir comment ça
s'organise on a en tout cas cinq
coureurs français aux avant-postes et
uniquement des équipes françaises
l'intrus entre guillemets c'est officiel
ce n 1 pour le team delko et très
bientôt l'entrée dans la cité
tourangelle
le ton semble pas très loin encore j'ai
cru le voir appuyé là les dix derniers
kilomètres jérémy sont propices à un
développement du peloton à une
progression du rythme du peloton mais
encore faut-il avoir des coéquipiers 1.6
et doré angot dont il n'est pas loin le
peloton n'est pas loin non plus sa forme
de nouveaux serait organisé un petit peu
dans le peloton ce que god on n'a pas
fait une erreur de ressortir comme ça
alors qu'il avait deux deux équipiers
devant un coton quatrième la semaine
dernière à cholet
lui aussi est en forme ce que ce n'est
pas lui qui a permis de relancer un
petit peu derrière et les coureurs
rentrent à tour par le pont du cher où
ça rentre ça revient il ne reste plus
que 8 km à cet endroit elle peloton
effectivement un sous l'impulsion
notamment des coureurs de l'équipe bingo
légalement qui font leur apparition or
les avait pas vus jusqu'à présent
effectivement avec des courants rapides
1 comme à maurice vallet kenny molly
moi je pense que oui dont on n'a pas
fait le meilleur choix stratégiques et
il semble même se relever un il
appellerait que le peloton allait
revenir
dorian baudon qui a peut-être un griller
sa cartouche un peu trop tôt les
coureurs sont dans tour
quel sera le sprinteur de l'équipe
ingall wallonie bruxelles à ça va être
chaud un suspense total sur la le final
de la roue tourangelle 19e du nom
il reste un peu plus de 6 km et on
rappelle que les coureurs vont passer
sur la ligne d'arrivée une première fois
il restera un tour de circuit 4000
mètres supplémentaires
alors ça c'est important parce que ça
permet jérémy un atout c'est courant a
notamment les sprinteurs de prendre
quelques repères avant la fatidique
arrive et oui c'est vrai que du coup
c'est une partie qu'ils retrouveront
dans quatre kilomètres maintenant à la
flamme rouge donc il reste bien 5 km 1
ne vous méprenez pas puisqu'il y aura
donc un tour de 4 km à l'issue du
passage ça frotte entre les motos et
venturi mois turini qui relance à
nouveau qui a profité de l'aspiration de
la moto pour prendre quelques mètres
mais regroupement général le peloton est
revenu
et là aussi un peut-être une occasion
gâchée pour un thomas boudât et pour
clément venturini arnaud démare hélas en
dixième position du peloton ce qui
aurait une équipe capable de brider la
course jusqu'à l'arrivée et qui bienne
be et semble bien en place
el nasr boisnier l'a également en
quatrième ou cinquième position du
peloton sans doute jonathan hivert qui
roule
kévin réza et là il n'y a plus qu'une 20
25 coureurs dans le peloton de la roue
tourangelle
c'est du jamais vu ça ou presque assez
souvent comme ça ce final il ya des
cours qui sont dispensés à chaque boss
ouais mais là elle n'y a vraiment plus
beaucoup de monde
les voici sur la ligne 4 kilomètres de
l'arrivée avec nacer bouhanni arnaud
démare c'était thibault ferracin pour
l'équipe b n bill qui emmenait
4h48 d'efforts déjà on sera tous proches
des cinq heures pour aller au bout de
cette troisième manche de la coupe de
france vous rappelle que le collectif
ag2r citroën est première au classement
par équipes
viviani et paraît pas entre sont les
deux premiers vainqueurs qu'en sera-t-il
de cette troisième manche réponse dans
maintenant moins de quatre minutes
jonathan hivert qui fermait la marche de
ce peloton pierre luc périchon qui
relance la lure avec un ce format
critérium maintenant un portable ou
tourangelle c'est vrai petit format
critérium en circuit urbain le vire vire
où les coureurs tourneront sans cesse
sur la gauche et beaucoup de coureurs
distancés effectivement qu'ils nous
rejoignent sur la ligne aile perrichon
il a pris à une trentaine de mètres
ici l'ancien vainqueur d'étape sur le
tour savoie mont blanc sur
paris-camembert sur la polynormande là
pour les coureurs qui sont à l'arrière
du peloton à ce sera trop difficile de
remonter aux avant-postes à se diriger
vers un sprint à semble-t-il
oui parce que c'est terminé pour
perrichon l'hypothèse du sprint massif
prend de plus en plus d'épaisseur à une
dizaine de kilomètres on n'aurait pas
misé sur un sprint
vu le déroulement de la course
on rappelle les candidats un jérémy
umbrella pasqua l'one pour l'équipe
intermarché ou un petit caubère arnaud
démare le champion de france de la
groupama fdj simonet comme sony pour la
cofidis marc sarreau de l'équipe ag2r
citroën nicolau bonifacio pour total
direct energie ou encore nacer bouhanni
le coureur de l'équipe arkéa samsic
voilà les principaux candidats
on peut y ajouter évidemment pierre
barbier damiano ccima matteo malucelli
thanks équipe i know x5 rôles et
attention à sorel varennes skull da dont
je vous parlais tout à l'heure également
ce jeune garçon qui est très puissant
alors attention à ce petit temps mort à
une attaque avec le maillot ag2r citroën
qui reprend un petit peu de place aux
avant postes ouais le ton qui s'est re
densifier un avec une trentaine d'hommes
mais dans un mouchoir de poche et les
coureurs vont passer très bientôt sous
la flamme rouge
alors oui arnaud démare pour l'instant
un tout petit peu loin près par le
sprint de mark sa roue avec cette
accélération en tête du collectif ag2r
citroën qui pop qui pour s'imposer dans
cette troisième manche de la coupe de
france les coureurs vont aller chercher
la flamme rouge très très belle dernière
heure tout allait l'argent en cinquième
position juste derrière nacer bouhanni
bouanik et emmenée par bram walton en
deuxième position whelton deuxième
boigny troisième démarré deux places
plus loin
adhémar bois ni bois ni des marins c'est
sur le papier le choc que l'on attend
depuis un moment on râle verdict au
terme de cette longue ligne droite de
500 m la flamme rouge le dernier
kilomètre il restera donc un dernier
virage et rami et ensuite place au
boulevard jean royer qui livrera donc le
verdict au terme de ces deux sont 4 km
et après 200 kilomètres évidemment le
sprint pourrait être bien différent
nacer bouhanni à deux équipiers encore
mais attention ça risque de faire juste
faut pas qu'ils se découvrent trop tôt
pour qu'il ait son dernier équipier qui
le lâchent dans les 200 derniers mètres
on ne serait ce pas à bouddha qui emmène
maintenant c'est le ton là ça me semble
bouder actuellement à l'est la dernière
ligne droite les 500 derniers mètres
thomas boudât la première place bramwell
tenait dans sa roue bramwell tonnes qui
lance maintenant le sprint petit à petit
on est à 300 mètres de la ligne
ça va être limpide avec un bois ni
démarre mark strong et 8 s
hoyé démarre sa roue aux trois premières
positions c'est toujours whelton qui
lance le sprint maintenant nacer
bouhanni face à arnaud démare les deux
hommes les deux ténors du sprint
français sont au coude à coude
arnaud démare qui prend les devants et
100 de charge en ces temps de réponse
qu'il s'impose facilement au terme de ce
sprint massif première victoire cette
saison pour arnaud démare le champion de
france qui s'impose sur la 19e édition
de la roue tourangelle
il devance à son adversaire nacer
bouhanni qui prend donc la 2e place
arnaud démare était venu jérémy pour a
remporté un premier bouquet en 2021
c'est maintenant chose faite il a bien
contrôlé il s'est fait peur mais il a
bien contrôlé avec ses co équipiers de
groupama fdj cette dernière heure qui
fut passionnante
oui final très très passionnant avec
effectivement la première victoire d'un
os démarre cette saison
et peut-être que l'équipe marqué à
samsic effectivement on a n'a pas pu
faire autrement de la manoeuvre était
très bien mais ça manquait peut-être un
petit peu de vitesse pour le lancement
et arnaud démare était dans la position
idéale en fait en troisième position à
ce moment là de la course il ya plus
lancé son sprint quasiment en même temps
que nacer bouhanni mais en ayant un peu
plus de vitesse
regardez là il se lance déjà arnaud
démare et il va pouvoir déborder en
survitesse par rapport à nos cerveaux ni
il va le doublé tout de suite envoyé
binyam gear mais qui a été également
dans le coup me semble-t-il
bon allez prendre une place d'honneur
arnaud démare donc vainqueur nacer
bouhanni prend la deuxième place de
cette épreuve l on revoit donc le sprint
dans les tout derniers mètres
marc sarreau peut-être pour la troisième
place
oui marc sarreau pour la troisième
position et je me demande si un autre
coureur de l'équipe arkéa samsic n'était
pas également bien représentées pour
aller chercher la place de 4e
ce freeware ce serait étonnant quand
même que ce soit un coureur qui as un
psychiatre chercher la quatrième place
marc sarreau pont la troisième position
et le podium dont démarre bouhanni ça
reste un beau podium 1 ça c'est clair
un podium qui fera date dans l'histoire
de la roue tourangelle avec la victoire
du champion de france 14 succès l'année
dernière son premier bouquet en 2021
en ce dimanche 4 avril
et on sera en mesure de vous donner dans
un instant le classement le top 10 de
cette édition les sports que l'on vous
donnera un à l'oral
ici sur les dernières images de cette
très très belle épreuve la roue
tourangelle un beau succès sportif un
régime à jean la fierté de bernard match
durait toute son équipe qui se sont
démenés depuis il ya des jours à des
semaines mais surtout ces dernières
heures qui est qu'elles furent
compliquées et et on n'a pas vu encore
directement bernard matches ferme on
imagine sa fierté et le soulagement et
le soulagement
on a vécu une belle manche de la coupe
de france avec une très très belle
dernière heure notamment de nombreuses
attaques un beau parcours évidemment
sous le soleil de la touraine
[Musique]
soulagement également pour arnaud démare
qui on le sait quand on est sprinteur a
manqué quelques occasions même s'il n'a
pas beaucoup de regrets à avoir sur son
début de saison quand on est sprinteurs
on veut ce corps est très vite
oui quand on est sprinteurs ce qui
compte c'est la victoire faut lever les
bras d'autant plus qu'il y avait de
nouvelles attentes autour de lui un
suite à sa saison 2020 à qui fut
absolument incroyable en l'espace de
quelques semaines et quelques mois il a
engrangé 14 victoires et ses salles peux
dire c'est que tous les compteurs sont
remis à zéro à chaque année et voilà le
losc aurait effectivement font reprendre
confiance pour reprendre ses
automatismes et on peut pas rester sur
les acquis des années précédentes et
voilà j'espère pour lui que que voilà le
c'est reparti avec cette victoire il va
pouvoir de nouveau repartir sur une
belle spirale avec ses équipiers et son
train habituel
l'équipe groupama fdj qui en profite
pour aller chercher donc une un beau
succès 1 sur les routes de touraine à
l'occasion de la roue tourangelle
l'équilbre ou pas magique il en profite
pour empocher également la deuxième
victoire de sa saison 2021
après la victoire de david gaudet qui
s'était imposé sur la faune ardèche
classique
jérémy donc la fin d'une très très belle
édition remportée par le champion de
france 1 vainqueurs de prestige du côté
de la tour n 1 sous un beau soleil sur
un beau parcours et arnaud démare qui
lance bel et bien sa saison quelques
images 1 pour rendre l'antenne ici sur
les routes de tourner la roue
tourangelle qui a qui a tourné en faveur
des organisateurs et en faveur d'arnaud
des moeurs jérémy ce fut un plaisir
merci ce fut un plaisir également je
suis ravi d'avoir pu vivre cette très
belle course à vos côtés avec deux un
très beau podium démarre bois ni soro
c'étaient les têtes d'affiché annoncée
donc voilà c'est un plaisir de que ce
soit conclu de fort belle manière
merci à toutes et à tous de nous avoir
suivis c'était le live de la roue
tourangelle sur les antennes de france 3
régions france 3 centre val de loire et
sur le site internet de la roue
tourangelle encore un grand bravo à
l'ensemble de l'équipe d'organisation
bravo donc à arnaud démare qui s'impose
devant nacer bouhanni et marc sarreau un
podium franco français à l'issue de
cette 19e édition
on vous laisse en images avec le
protocole qui va débuter tout à l'heure
merci de nous avoir suivi et à très vite
pour d'autres aventures sur la coupe de
france de cyclisme
[Musique]